[Music]
n
he
[Music]
Bo
aahah
[Music]
oh
come
[Music]
oh
he's down a piece he's down two Pawns
couple of checks magnus's King is going
to dance easily out of them take my
queen and give me a new one please he's
losing now he walked right into the and
they know it they know it turn your
boards 909 952 made a big mistake oh and
the bar is going up this is an absolute
Gem of a game Wesley saw has done it
he's going in for the attack but he's
walked into Checkmate black can play
Rook takes
porn one move Checkmate two seconds oh
my God why
arm high stakes matches today four
biggies in the elimination bracket two
will be knocked out the drama about to
begin welcome everyone to the chess B
Masters I'm International Master T SV
alongside me there's no chess with our
grandm hes and the ever brilliant grandm
David how guys we've got a big day ahead
of us Robert loving the pink chair what
are you most hyped about today well I
mean can we predict any more upsets
because that would be something special
yesterday was a day of the underdog
Alicia Keys would be very
proud it feels like the stakes are
higher than ever there's more on the
line and as Tanya you mentioned two
players will leave it's not just any two
players those players in the elimination
bracket now four of the world's best so
there's definitely going to be blood
spiled I can't wait for the action the
four player players in the elimination
any one of them could be the tournament
winner they're that strong we'll Deep
dive more into that but first let's
check out the dates for this year's 2024
Champions chest four regular events
leading up to the tour and in-person
live finals in December we're in the
chessel Masters mark your calendars the
four winners of each of these four
events will qualify for the December
finals and Robert also the ever
important tour standings the players are
feeling the pressure they certainly are
because from the GetGo you're looking
how many points am I going to gain from
this performance if I don't in fact win
the section so these players they know
what's at stake a lot of money and only
four events this year compared to six a
season
ago fewer events the pressure is on and
the pressure was on yesterday as well
what an exciting start it was few would
have predicted the winners the way the
games went yesterday and if you're a fan
of the story of The Underdogs yesterday
was a
blockbuster the play-ins the placements
they were super exciting but here we go
we have lifted off it is the KO this
time it's the white king that's running
up the board both Kings have been doing
a bit of dancing here but the white king
is doomed no way to escape you step fors
F5 there's going to be a deadly check on
F3 and uh White has to lose even more
material yanish she smiles and he's
about to resign J been he gets the DB
massive massive drama on the Wesley
board as Wesley gets flagged Robert what
happened can he give a petrol check if
not black promotes and wins Rook to D7 a
blunder black deflects the rook and wins
the game is over fed takes it what a
defensive F by him J B is about to take
this Victory we saw Yan pishi just smile
again shake his head Jose Martinez is on
a roll he has a superpower and he knows
how to use it he has a low rating and
this is for everyone out there at home
if you're playing someone higher rated
you can just play solid you can bully
them and uh use it against them and then
we see resignation Dennis wins it
incredible Chess By
[Music]
Dennis it was a day of celebrations
three under 2700 players have made it
through to division one of the cherille
Masters and they remain in the winnner
bracket start with eight players on
Friday we see four go down in into the
losers bracket meanwhile Dennis Las Vick
Magnus
Carlson Vladimir fedos continue their
run in to the winners bracket they will
be fighting it out but before that we've
also got the action coming in from the
losers bracket where we've got four
Heavy Hitters Maxim VRA takes on Yan
pishi wesy so will take on Ali razza
fuja big fights David who impressed you
the most on on day one of The Knockouts
well it wasn't any of those four players
in the elimination bracket the losers
bracket unfortunately I'm going to go uh
instead however for those underdogs
Dennis lavic and Jose Martinez just uh
showing that being the underdog having
their opponents push harder trying to
take them down and kind of showing them
maybe a little less respect than they
deserve uh it has worked in their favor
and especially for young Dennis lazovic
nerves are still undefeated yesterday in
five games including an armag against
Maxi V it was just a fantastic
display of
solidity and we have it Dennis against
Maxim four draws in the rapid the
Armageddon the Frenchman never really
got a chance and never got his
opportunity with the white pieces Dennis
lavic kept it solid we've got their
postmatch stats Robert what stands out
to you in this one it's the accuracy
from the youngster he is such a solid
style that he avoids really heavy
mistakes but what's interesting to note
is down at the bottom there it was
Dennis lazik who actually had a blunder
in one of the games but it didn't matter
because when it came down to it he only
needed a draw in Armageddon he did not
need to win the game so the blunders
they weren't real they were not found
and that is why Dennis lack he moved on
with that Stellar play yeah and I've
noticed he's just so good with these
armag gons we also saw that in the
Toronto finals of the previous season we
saw that in the match play here when he
took down Anish G and then yest today
against Maxim he managed to get the
black pieces he outsmarted him in the
bids and then never gave him the chance
another player who never gave his
opponent a chance was Jose Martinez
playing against the two-time world
championship Challenger yan yan a big
favorite on paper but David to my eyes
it just felt that Yan was completely out
of form
yesterday right we saw Yan pom Nishi not
show his best a blunder in one one of
the early games and there was simply no
way back Jose was too solid too strong
after that and took his chances when
they came Martinez he's a man in form he
was so uh impressive during the play-ins
as well and uh this time format 10
minutes on the clock two second
increment really seems to suit him so
yanomi he will hopefully step through
the gears today he needs to in that
losers bracket but Jose Martinez want to
watch he's definitely definitely uh the
man of the moment so far yeah one of the
four players on their last lives today
in the elimination bracket for Jose
Martinez it has been the Cinderella
story so far on his 25th birthday he
convincingly wins the Swiss play-ins
then goes on to B his spot in division
one Robert what impressed you the most
about Jose
yesterday pretty much everything his
composure the fact that when he gets in
time trouble he proves why he's a main
state of the bullet Chess Championship
year in and year out he's won a number
of the bullet bws he's a a streamer a
content creator sure but he's also an
exceptional player and a very strong
Grand Master just because he doesn't
venture to over theboard tournaments
that can be expensive for many players
does not mean that he doesn't pack a
powerful punch and he's able to deliver
in those waning seconds because he is
that strong he is that strong and one
other player who is super strong and he
needs no introduction at all of course
he continues his run in the Winner's
bracket it is Magnus Carlson who won his
match against Wesley so and today he
will take on Vladimir fedos it's the big
fish versus the biggest fish David what
are we expecting from this one where
does fed have create his chances against
Magnus Carson well he simply has to look
to the other underdogs for inspiration
all of these lower rated players rising
up but also he is a confident man fed
remember the world rapid Championship as
recently as the end of December feder
got the silver medal yes Magnus got gold
but he knows on his day he can hang with
the best and uh actually for Magnus
Carson this is not going to be a
walkover fed has had a few uh kind of
games where he has been successful
against Magnus in the past uh so both
players if they bring their best it's
going to be a close fight and one of
those famous examples is when Magnus
Carlson a few years back he was trolling
coming onto chess.com trying to take
over the number one rating in Blitz and
you know who stopped him the big fish
Vladimir fedos said not so fast my
friend and he took him down he was every
bit his equal in that Blitz match this
is rapid it's different type of show but
the best part of fedos is he bends but
he does not break he is super
resourceful as he showed yesterday
against fuia yeah what a match that was
that's quite a comeback victory for
fedos he lost the first game and then
finally winning in the last round took
the match scored two wins in those best
of four Vladimir FV has to bring in the
same form he has to bring in is his aame
as he faces the three time and the
reigning door champion
fed have continues the run in the
winnner bracket and it's not just him
we've got another another big matchup uh
in the Winner's bracket as Dennis uh
lazovic will be fighting it out against
jpim as well now while these guys still
have two lives left there are four
players who are on their last life and
two names that I think would surprise
everyone and few would have predicted at
the start Wesley so against Ali Resa one
of them will be elimin ated today now
looking at their form coming in from day
one what do we make of this matchup and
is there a favorite in this one
Robert oh this is a tossup but players
with very different styles what we tend
to appreciate what Wesley so super solid
ala fuja he makes chaos happen he's kind
of like the Joker and he is willing to
shake things up so this is a huge Clash
of styles a clash of generations I do
not know who to pick cuz a year ago they
both had four divisions one appearances
it proves that they are both Mighty and
hard to take
down a clash of styles a clash of
generations David this is going to be a
fun one what do you think will be the
key factor the key decisive factor in
this matchup just about who can get
their style of play Going On The Board
as Robert mentioned uh fuja he's the
agent of chaos all hell breaks loose uh
when he plays these days has been up and
down win loss that was the story of his
tournament yesterday as well uh but for
Wesley so if he can quiet down the game
if he can change the pace uh maybe go
into slower grindy endgame type of
positions then Wesley will stand great
chances but judging on yesterday's form
FIA wants that fire on the board um so
the games are going to be fascinating no
matter what yeah it's going to be a lot
about who gets their kind of position
whenever there's a clash of styles so
much depends on how the opening
progresses into the middle game which
player is more comfortable with the kind
of structures that appear on the board
it's going to be a fun battle with high
stakes but that's not the only one our
other big U match in the elimination
bracket as Maxim Vash lra takes on Yan
neom Nishi both players lost on day one
they are on their last life and one of
them will I want to say go home but they
are playing from home but they will get
eliminated from the chessel Masters um
now to me these two players of course
two of the best players in the world but
they were just both off for maxim never
got his kind of positions against Dennis
lavic thatn has always kept it under
control what does he need to do today
against Yan pomsi both very Dynamic
players both very Dynamic players Maxim
maybe just needs to use all of his
opening uh Weaponry his arsenal of these
fantastically kind of pinpointed opening
prep but uh Yan he's a bit of a moving
Target these days especially online uh
it just depends what mood he's in quite
often so um as you say t it's about who
of this 1990 generation a kind of clash
of the 33 year olds who comes into it
hotter I actually feel the first player
to win the game win a game here will uh
just cruise through I think uh both
players at this point they're just a bit
Restless they're just ready and um yeah
I don't think either is in the right
mindset to uh kind of bounce back if yet
another kind of setback happens so it's
going to be fascinating to watch I think
Vash gra was a bit more solid yesterday
but who knows Y is
capable and Yan is ready to go as we see
him on the camera he better be ready to
go with the players on their last life
and David you're absolutely right there
is no margin for error in the losers
bracket it's a best of two you lose one
game it's so difficult to come back with
just one more game left so they've got
to keep things under control and Yan
looks very amused right now well it's
because he knows how the horse he moves
apparently and you see yanomi all smiles
the moment but when it's game time he is
serious yesterday was not his day he was
said instead focused on Twitter rather
than on the chess today he has to go
right back to the board against Maxim
vasher lrav someone he knows very well
in fact when yand pomi won his first
candidates he overtook Maxim those two
were neck and neck in the first half of
that delayed candidates tournament so
these two have history for Yan pomi he
does not want history from yesterday to
repeat himself he wants to continue here
in division
one it's a big big match up coming up
yanami taking on Maxim V while earlier
on Twitter it looked like the two were
friendly right now David all friendship
has to be kept off the board it is all
focused the gloves have to come off the
players high pressure right now what do
you think is going to be the opening
approach in this one for Yan it's so
better to leave that Twitter side show
to one side for now um I feel that
Yan depends right he's got the candid
Ates on the horizon he doesn't really
want to show off his best openings but
if he does employ his best openings uh
the Spanish with white you know the
Petro with black all of his kind of um
yeah his kind of aame U kind of openings
then I actually feel he has a chance but
yeah the players when they freestyle
anything can happen it's so hard to
predict that smile on the face as well
it was there throughout yesterday it
seemed to distract him he wasn't fully
focused and both players actually
smiling and yeah really to see this
mindset it's just about who settles in
quicker um this 10-minute time format
traditionally might favor Maxim Vash lra
he's super quick super instinctive
yesterday Yan was kind of yet to find
his rhythm but um I'm not making a
prediction Tanya I'm not brave enough
how about
you yeah it's going to be tough to
predict this one David Robert and David
you mentioned this time format 10
minutes with a 2C increment very
different from last year where the
player started with 15 minutes and 3
second increment at this level how much
of a difference is that one second what
does how does that change the Dynamics
for these players David massive
especially when the clocks tick down um
the players at some point will reach
that climax of the game when it's really
messy when the tactics are flying and
there it's just pure Instinct so two
seconds disappears instantly we even saw
Wesley so lose on time yesterday that's
how quickly the increment can disappear
and uh both of these players known for
their speed they don't really want to
get down to those time scrambles and
usually it's just about who's in the
better shape who's in better form here
we go though it is the Petro defense uh
one that I named dropped earlier showing
how much yand pesi wants to win this
game he's taking it seriously this
tournament the Chester ball Masters he
wants to win it we see a trade of Pawns
in the center this is still the main
line of the Petro defense until now not
the most common move white bringing out
a bishop blocking the D Pawn but uh this
D Pawn will later most likely move often
white pushes the pawn forward drops the
bishop back and then the D Pawn is free
so clearly preparation a bit of a battle
here we see on the left side of our
boards um the percentages of the U the
kind of outcome of this opening white
tends to win 47% of the time that's a
huge score I've got to say uh but yand
pomi he's got more time in the tank
Robert what do you make of these early
moves these early decisions I'm honestly
most surprised by Maxim vra's time usage
he's one of the quickest players on the
planet as is yand pami and we are seeing
a pawn sacrifice in the moment so white
is about to take twice goes up a pawn
black gets a pair of Bishops on an open
board so that is compensating for the
material deficit but as I look just at
the clock yanomi in his preparation it
was Maxim who played an offbeat opening
and Tanya are you as surprised as I am
to see that it's Maxim playing something
of a Seline and yet he's the one using
his
clock definitely and uh robber we'
spoken so much about preparation and
this is that something that has to be
Yan P's world championship prep but for
maxim he's still in the think with that
last move so I'm just trying to
understand there are so many natural
developing moves here you can take the
Knight out to C3 you could double up on
the E Line attacking the bishop what
goes on in a grandmaster's mind at this
early stage when obvious moves are in
front of you to slow down what is Maxim
thinking about here David Maxim he's the
most instinctive player I've ever met
I've played him since we were both 8
years old and normally in a position
like this he would kind of throw the
moves down the board they'd be flying
out Pawn to D3 like you said bring the
bishop out bring the Knight out he won't
stop to calculate until it's really
necessary but he knows he's walked into
some opening preparation here and hence
his last move he's trying to simplify
the equation um that is not yand pishi I
can confirm that is Wesley so on the
camera unless uh something magic has
happened but yeah he's just trying to
get rid of a set of Pawns trying to
simplify the equation since he is one
Pawn ahead um but Robert's right uh the
time usage is really mysterious I have
actually seen yand ponesi employ this
porn sacrifice in the past it is known
so Maxim may be surprised by the
employment of the pet defense uh maybe
just didn't spend too much time
preparing wanting to stay fresh instead
either way he's getting out of the
opening and once white recaptures black
also has an issue how to develop these
pieces if the black bishops start
playing then I do fear for white despite
the extra Pawn so Robert how would you
evaluate the Practical chances of this
Gambit the sacrifice well this last
decision to offer a trade of Queens I
think is a good practical one from Maxim
VRA we often tell our newer members of
the audience our students to trade
pieces when you're ahead white is a pawn
up so if the Queens could come off the
board and also if the Rooks later leave
then that extra Pawn will make its
presence felt it is a C2 Pawn but later
you can use it as a pass Pawn push it
forward so the Bishops they are long
range pieces they can poke and prod on
both flanks that's the good news the bad
news for Jan is he is down upon and I
don't see the clear-cut compensation I
don't see something he can Target he is
now playing defense a bit he's going to
prevent white from pushing those pawns
forward and the queen trade has happened
you see the evaluation bar slightly
inching upwards for white I would agree
with that assessment I would certainly
love to have this a dream position for
Maxine yeah
he's got the extra pawn and David sorry
but I was just going to say peace is
traded off Queen's traded off he's got
the extra Pawn The Bishop's coming out
it just looks like yanan's going to be
fighting it out for a draw here it feels
like a game for two results to me I was
about to kind of preach about how you
should trade on your terms not your
opponent's terms I was really surprised
to see yand pomi take off that Queen in
the center a few movs ago because now
White's Knight is really well solidified
look at this it looks like a granite
statue in the middle of the board
protected by this Pawn protected by the
bishop it's on a square we call an
outpost and the only way to get rid of
it uh effectively is to trade off these
Knights but now if white does take the
Black Knight the black pawns will be
shattered I'm expecting that to happen
any moment now uh what else simply for
white the compensation here for black
will lie in this bishop being a bit of a
nasty pest here along the diagonal just
reminding the white pawns on the queen
side that they're slightly vulnerable
and this bishop if it can get into the
game if there is a trade of knights for
example via this diagonal then uh the
ship do start to play a role so still
not over but I agree with both of you at
the very minimum white should be able to
return a pawn and kind of bail out into
a draw so it's very much a two result
type of position where it's white trying
to make things happen trying to cling on
trying to profit from the extra material
but essentially black objectively should
be fine this is really reminiscent of
the Marshall Gambit and other E4 E5
openings that some of our viewers might
know where black gives up upon PA but
has
long-term and watch out for the B file
to become uh a bit of a pressure point
in the near future but for now these two
weaknesses do give black the questions
to answer white night is
coming small Advantage I think we're all
in agreement here for white this the
first time for everything right we're
all agreeing white is better it's a safe
position the Knight as you mentioned can
venture to B3 and C5 or up to E4 into
the center and unfortunately for Jan he
has his own weaknesses to worry about a
Pawn's best friend is another Pawn David
you know I like to do this if you can
just grab that seat six pawn and Scoot
it over to B6 for a second while that
looks like a much more stable Foundation
where your pawns are connected but with
the pawns separated the way they are
that means that white can start
attacking them in fact the A7 Pawn
already means that the black Rook is
Tethered to it you can't easily move
that into the position because A7 will
drop so the Bishops are out Tanya we all
seem to be on the same page here but I
guess the question becomes how
challenging will it be for Jan to prove
that he can obtain that half Point yeah
that's a that's the big question here
Yan will be on the defense he's got the
bishop bear and the open b line and The
Rook on the D file also on the open file
as compensation so there's definitely
peace activity but at the end of it
Maxim up upon the night having these
good squares I think Maxim going to try
to get as much as he can from this
position will try to grind it out this
is a good moment to jump back to our
other high stakes game which we haven't
had a look at um as wesy so takes on Ali
RZA fuja one of these two players will
be eliminated should we check in with
our other two Heavy Hitters let's do
just that Tanya as we see ala fua
starting with the white pieces against
Wesley so and uh I was going to say
Wesley so solid because this is Rock
Solid for black no weaknesses at all
it's what we call the kpad pawn
structure uh whenever we see a pawns on
E3 and D4 faced off by pawns on C6 and
D5 but with a Twist this time because
white has already advanced a pawn to F4
pros and cons here you have more central
control but a bit of a backward Pawn now
the backward Pawn on E3 is a bit tender
you'll be stuck defending it for a long
time I've got to say I'm surprised the
evaluation bar is uh kind of slightly in
White's favor here unless it's because
of this move opening up the center um I
would have thought black is doing
completely fine but suddenly questions
to answer the black queen is hit this is
very Dynamic now up for's allei we're
talking about who wants their style of
position of game and uh White is
suffering longterm white has a weak
isolated Queen's Pawn this F4 Pawn very
tender as well but for now this queen
hit the F6 Pawn a bit of a Target as
well um Robert you're great with these
tactics do you see any trouble here for
Wesley so is if he just Retreats his
Queen for example is he still as solid
as it looks at first glance well white
is going to start throwing pieces
forward especially if that Queen goes to
C7 away from the black king I think F5
is the next move that Ali Razer wants to
cork let's open up that diagonal for the
queen to land on H6 let's go for tactics
in front of the black king So for Wesley
the long term is great for him white has
this isolated Pawn that is blockaded if
the Queens disappeared oh white is in
some danger in the long run the end game
would be one that Kappa Blanca could
only dream of may he Rest In Peace So as
I look at this position I think it
actually plays to both of these player
Styles in the immediate position white
can go on the prowl go for the black
king but if you stall if you head for
even a moment and black is able to
further consolidate and solidify the
position there are some long-term
weaknesses so F5 is in the board Tanya I
think that uh it's a battle of styles
here and both players are doing the
right
thing I completely agree with everything
that you've just said but I do like
White's position especially after that
move F5 and to complete your thought if
we just back up before Knight to D5 was
played David as black you really want to
keep things closed and you want to keep
your king side solid but I think the
tactics that you were pointing out
earlier if black does make the move like
G5 they're already on the board because
after G5 white can go Knight takes F6
pick up that pawn on F6 and suddenly
Queen takes G5 once you recapture the F6
Knight Falls and the whole King side
falls apart so there's really no way for
Wesley to keep the king side blocked
which means that the white Bishop on D3
and the pawn on F5 can open up after a
trade in the live on the live board and
I see the G6 Pawn indeed has been traded
off I think this position suits Ali RZA
Style just a little bit more than it
suits
Wesley I think David might uh be muted
right now as we could see him chatting
but nothing said David you back with
used about the
position I was just saying that um this
position I like it for white as well I'm
on Tanya's side it looks very attractive
for fua but he has to keeping it's like
riding a bicycle if you stop you might
fall off and uh longterm because he is
worse here he is kind of suffering with
this backward de Pawn this isolated Pawn
um longterm chances aren't great he has
to play for the attack so key moment
he's stopped he's thinking he's actually
quite significantly down on the clock
but moves like Queen to H6 strikeout
look really really attractive at some
point you might consider throwing
battering ram down the board with your H
Pawn uh if Wesley's able to trade off
pieces Wesley will be loving life watch
out for Wesley for example bring the
black queen forward and offering that
trade so very much in the balance as we
see this real Clash of styles both
players playing true to their character
here really fascinating to
watch yeah and I think it's a kind of
position where if the pieces get traded
off like you're pointing out with Queen
to F4 these long-term weaknesses that
white has the isolated Queen Pawn on D4
these will come into play and give black
give Wesley chances to perhaps fight for
more so for alira it's really key to try
to make most of the initiative on the
king side I love the idea of putting the
queen on 86 Robert how can actually Ali
Resa try to keep the Queens on the board
because now that I see Queen H6 Queen F4
actually forces a queen trade and that
is certainly not what Aliva wants so
he's trying to make this Checkmate
happen but you can't will it into
existence and that's the problem
especially for newer players who love to
try to deliver a Checkmate you think I'm
going after the opponent's king I'm
going to Checkmate them and then they
just trade the Queens off and you feel a
little bit lost like you don't have any
chest left in you and so for aldera here
comes the queen trade he's strong enough
where of course he he doesn't feel at a
loss he is great in the end game as well
but as I look at the clocks and I look
at the position I have to say Advantage
Wesley so he has been able to Stave off
that first wave of attack he's in good
shape and with the pieces coming off I
really don't see the problem for black
anymore looks great for black I've got
to say um I'm going to revise my opinion
just from one move ago or two moves ago
now that the Queens have left the only
Solace for white is that you have access
to this D6 Square the White Knight does
jump in so uh the trade of the Queens
longterm again great for black but short
term white is hitting uh this porn white
is trying to cause some nuisance now
infiltrating potentially on the seventh
rank will The Rook jump in again you
have to play actively you have to play
dynamically to keep the momentum uh
before you fall off that bike and uh in
the meantime threats black threatening
to take this Knight maybe threatening to
take this Pawn as a deflection but yeah
playing energetically as predicted
hitting this night evaluation bar
stubbornly in the middle who's uh just
before we switch back to the other game
whose position do we feel is easier to
play now that the Queens
off I wish say I would say White's
activity now is speaking to me but
Black's position is better but in The
Other Board we see a rook trade on offer
between Maxim Vash lra and yand pomi on
the left and this is a critical moment
in that game because if Jan trades Rooks
he better have calculated 15 moves ahead
as his Pawn structure is weaker so this
is one of these end games on the left
hand side of our screen here that we do
not take for granted it is pure
calculation if you're y Palm that's why
he's invested already over 30 seconds I
could see him thinking for another
minute but even if you don't trade Rooks
in this position you've still got to be
careful right because white king can try
and March over to D4 it just feels like
Black's Pawn structure is so terrible on
that left side of our screen right now
so if anyone's trying to push this it's
got to be Maxim but David realistically
what are the chances with the Rook on
the board given Black's weaknesses is
there real metal to try in this
position unfortunately I think that
chances are minimal he's playing a great
defender in yanomi someone who'll defend
actively I really like Black's last move
on that left board on our screens uh
blacks pushing the H Pawn forward just
edging uh towards making yet another
trade the black king might March forward
to I think it's just too little material
it's h too reduced your artillery here
just no real winning chances if you were
playing someone lower rated maybe Maxi
Vash G would get excited but unlikely
against Yan also look at the clock times
in that left on that left board two
minutes against four I simply don't
think Vash grav is going to be anything
at all a draw by far the most likely
result in that one even if white is
having slightly the better of it
symbolically so um yeah we're predicting
a draw on the left side of the board in
the meantime Wesley so has frozen on the
other one uh the white Rook has landed
on E7 and suddenly the clock times have
balanced out there Robert you mentioned
that um board clock slightly favored
Wesley uh are you still of the same
opinion after this long think and then
he makes a move oh but this is actually
a huge moment on the right hand side of
our screens because Wesley so his Rook
is the only piece protecting his Knight
so the White Knight can put pressure on
The Rook I know this may be a bit
difficult for people to visualize but on
the right hand board the Knight can
attack The Rook to try to kick it but
the black king will step closer to the
white Rook that is what's holding on for
Wesley so he invested the time wisely
and he's worked it out you see the
evaluation bar still in the middle but
actually on left hand side of our
screens the evaluation bar is going up
and up in Maxim vasher lra's favor this
isn't just a drawn end game Maxim is
pushing commentator curse Tanya I might
have jinxed him there Maxim you asking
about winning chances maybe he's created
some it looks like he's just pushed his
FB that D5 weakness is forever there
black needs to trade on G3 but I'm still
thinking about the right side board that
we were pointing out the move Knight B7
that you mentioned earlier hitting that
Rook we might be seeing a repetition
with Black's King shuffling one step to
the left and one step to the right King
f8 King G8 just pursuing White's Rook on
the E7 87 Square Wesley so shaking his
head there but he's got nothing to be
worried about right now what are the
chances of these guys going in for the
repetition Right Here Right
Now the more that fuja is in the tank
the more his clock drops down the more
inclined he will be towards failing out
with a draw uh you can escape here with
white you can force the issue and take a
draw if you want and we're seeing that
Motif happen on the right side of your
screen look at this the black king
stepping left stepping right hitting the
white rook and uh where to go no Escape
squares a trade of Rooks and actually
that will clearly favor Black so I think
this is the time for fuan to bail out
meantime in The Other Board the
evaluation bar has gone through the roof
suddenly is white winning Maxim Vash
grav is he going to win this Rook end
game fuja against so is indeed a draw by
repetition it's time to focus Maxim Vash
gra this end game he's working some
magic suddenly npom she leans back and
realizes there's big trouble white SE PA
is simply going to March up the board
how to stop this Simple Plan of
promoting the pawn what he missed
because as you said the carpet has been
rolled out for that c pawn and black is
down a pawn even though material is
equal let that sink in the material is
even both sides have two pawns but black
kind of has one and this is why double
pawns are so bad this is why your
coaches tell you you want to avoid it if
you can because one white pawn stops two
of blacks David I'm going to have you do
that thing again pick up the F7 Pawn for
a second just hover it or that yes to E6
you can create a pass Pawn you can't do
it when there are two Pawns in a row
like this and white on the other hand
play C4 C5 C6 and so on and it gets the
other
side really nicely explained there
Robert that essentially white has an
extra Pawn it's pushing forward and The
Rook on D5 is so nicely placed because
it makes sure that the black king can
never actually pass through and defend
that c Pawn from a queening it's
attacking the F5 Pawn it's blocking off
the defile and it looks like Yan she is
in big trouble easy moves for
white moves and he's calculated so well
here the mathematician Maxim Vash GRA
with that education he is so good in
these positions where it's just a race
white is marching forward not just that
but the once the white Pawn steps
forward the white Rook will actually
step behind to block any attempts by the
black Rook to give itself up and uh I'm
not sure if there's even any time to go
and grab this white Pawn he has to try
it because what else you have to take
that pawn and Hope to get the black Rook
back but two squares away now and it
will be soon touchdown once the pawn
lands on C7 it will be unstoppable the
she shaking his head he knows it's
inevitable now he's let it slip what was
I I think commentator's curse again I
was claiming a dead drawn end game it's
gone five moves later he's busted that's
how difficult these end games are I need
to go back and study my Rook end the
games that's for sure Nishi maybe just
rushing a bit he still had a few minutes
left on his clock when he made that
mistake but fair play toasu impressive
smooth sailing we said it was a two
result game he squeezed water from a
stone here Maxim VRA felt it that there
was something to fight for in that
position where Yana pomi declined The
Rook trades it looked so close to a draw
but it all comes down to this Pawn
structure he managed to create the pass
pawn and like you mentioned there's no
time for black to even grab the F4 Pawn
we've been talking about that Rook on D5
once the C pawn moves forward that Rook
on D5 will slide one step towards the
left side and block any defensive ideas
on the sea line as well the king and the
Rook playing an impressive role in
assisting the C Pawn this is Maxim bash
lra's game he knows it he leans back and
the graph below the board tells the full
story here it was even and I think that
yand pomi he was led into a sense of
complacency I'll make a draw every
single time I get this position not
today not now and the the problems were
with his Pawn structure he had these
split pawns and this D5 Pawn in
particular was a weakness and now it's
off the board only white has a passer
Black's King it's slowly marching
towards the side of the board white can
even give up The Rook to get a new Queen
but I'm not sure if that's necessary
like why don't you just bring your Rook
to the final Rank and then push your
Pawn after it just don't give black even
a semblance of Hope here queen versus
Rook is a win theoretically speaking but
when you don't have much time on your
clock it can be difficult to prove so I
like keeping The Rook on the board and
then pushing the
pawn Robert The Profit again he drops
his Rook back the pawn is going to
promote not much to do about it uh the
one will cost the black Rook his life
Tanya I think we'll see a resignation
any moment
now yes absolutely I think Yana pomi
knows it as well the king is extremely
strong on B5 and just marches forward to
assist that C7 Pawn The Rook on D3
making sure that the black king can't
come and defend that C8 Square pieces
are beautifully placed and notice how
black still hasn't even managed to
create a pass pawn and that is it Yan
pishi cannot fight the C7 Pawn he
resigns Maxim takes the win wow this end
game just turned around really fast
Robert it did and that's what happens
when you think that you're for sure
going to make a draw I don't blame Yan
pomi on a good day he draws that game uh
for sure but not in this one Maxim Vash
never gave up he was ceaselessly
determined to fight for the full point
and he earned
it he earned it and we can see the shock
on yishi he knows it he was so close to
holding this with the black pieces this
is our score line going into the final
game of the elimination bracket yamna
pishi has to win on demand or it will be
the end of the road for him in the
chessable Masters meanwhile Wesley saw
alira fuja after quite an exciting
battle there in the opening the middle
game ended peacefully with with a draw
David this end game I'm still thinking
about it what was the turning around the
turnaround moment there that you felt
for
white I think it was just uh Maxim Vash
gra applying a little pressure setting
this trap deep in the end game and Yan
neishi falling into it it was actually
simply a case of yan relaxing as Robert
mentioned if he just protected his all
important Central Pawn if he'd activated
the black king a bit earlier then it
would have been a very different story
it should have been a relatively simple
draw but um yeah never relax in Rook in
games always think about what the
opponent wants think about the opponent
trying to trick you Yan his guard simply
wasn't up and in Rapid chess that is
brutal opponents are ruthless and we saw
it there one move and he was done that
was and now for Yana pushi he has to get
over it there is no time to recover only
one rapid game remains he must win on
demand meanwhile of course for Wesley so
alira fua it remains level and they've
got to fight it out in the next one what
are the chances of this matchup going
into the Armageddon Robert I think very
high because Wesley so doesn't take
tremendous risk if he doesn't have to
right if he's down a point and needs to
win he'll go all in but he drew game one
he is a ton of experience in Armageddon
from the Champions chess tour a year ago
and as we see a Kings Pawn open from
both sides the big question will we get
an Italian game well the answer is yes
instead of a Berlin and he's trying to
outmaneuver Ala later on so I do think
that this is Wesley style oh but he is
playing this trendy line uh we've seen
it a lot and you see to the left of the
board white does win quite a handful of
times but black wins his fair share
too my big question here is whether
Alisa fer has done his homework Wesley
actually employed this opening yesterday
against Magnus Carlson when he was
behind in the match and needed a win
with white and fuja here acting very
quickly and differently to Magnus in
that game yesterday uh so often you need
to keep an eye on what your opponent's
been doing in recent times you need to
prepare you need to have an idea up your
sleeve fuja here dropping the black
Bishop back I'm just waiting it's
something you referred to yesterday
Robert just for the chaos button Pawn to
G5 for that to be Unleashed yes it kicks
back the white Bishop but it also
weakens the black king so really
double-edged type of position and uh I'm
really glad I've got to say first of all
we're seeing the Italian not the Berlin
I was dreading it I thought oh straight
to Armageddon but no this one bubbling
nicely as there we go G5 on the
board this is definitely bubbling up and
we'll explore after that last move G5
it's a lot about the blink first game in
these openings both sides wait for a
castle uh from their opponent before
deciding to go G5 but in this position
Ali Reza does it with Wesley King still
in the center
and what are the chances especially
after that last move that we're going to
see Ali Razz's king castle on the other
side of the board is he looking for
safety on the queen side in an Ideal
World yes but that's uh the nature of
this opening where it's hard to make
that work because there are these pawns
for white already pushed on the queen
side the A4 Pawn is extended quite far
and the C3 Pawn helps white push B4 next
and eventually to B5 so I think the
black king is safest in the center for
now until white makes his intentions
clear and only then will you decide
where your Castle it could still be the
king side many players do that
especially if the white king heads there
first just as he says it he play as you
say it he plays it there Robert and now
it feels far safer for black to commit
to this side of the board now you know
your opponent's intentions no commitment
issues there for Wesley at least he gets
the white king to safety but fuja he's
actually going on a bit of a night dance
here the Black Knight wants to retreat
come around and sit on a really nice
perch not just defending the king side
in case he wants to Castle there but
also getting ready to push these black
horns down the board now that he knows
his opponent's intentions watch out for
this diagonal as well Black's Bishop a
raking piece from afar and uh this is
going to be mutual attacks white
advancing on the queen side black most
likely advancing on the other flank and
there we see a blue arrow that wasn't me
that was the computer saying Black's
best move by far is Knight to f8 so I'm
expecting that move to be played there
we go the players clearly Within their
homework a bit of home cooking here and
I can't wait to see this Pawn March down
the board for better or worse Black is
all in for the attack
now and the speed with which the players
are playing it clearly implies that
they're still in preparation right now
that last move Bishop to D5 avoiding any
trade you're pointing out the H Pawn
moving forward white will have to tackle
the threat of that Bishop on G3 getting
trapped which means that he have to push
his own H Pawn forward and very often
it's to H4 to make sure that black has
to take a decision with that g Pawn
either you close it with G4 or you try
to open up the G file I think we might
see a structure with H5 H4 and black
pushing
G4 you're very very likely to be correct
here Tanya um I've spent way too many
hours of my life analyzing this type of
position and that usually does happen
here we go first step of the plan big
threat on the board trying to trap this
bishop it's got no squares pushing a
pawn to H3 is simply too timid you give
black a free hand to choose which Pawn
to push black will blow open the
position on his terms so why not fix the
structure or at least ask the question
on your own terms and uh this is what
Wesley needs to go for um I'm trying to
recall my memory's getting up getting
worse as I get older but I'm pretty sure
I studied this exact position before and
H4 is the best move but we'll see what
Wesley has in store as Robert mentioned
the Italian game there's so many ways to
play it you can put your own personal
stamp on these lines but style-wise to
my eyes at least this is going to favor
all Razer if both players are on their
own he prefers this type of position
over Wesley that is 100% true and your
memory does serve you well if my memory
serves me well because I do believe that
H4 as you and Tanya both just mentioned
is the response that white needs to play
Here and After G4 well then the
difficult decisions continue to arise
because you hop forward to go for the
attack but your knight could get trapped
in enemy territory if we just show this
variation the pawn often can push up to
F6 and your knight has nowhere to go it
can continue jumping into the position
but that's the last stop on the night
tour because the Rook slides up to H7
you're getting ready to take or try to
play Move Like Bishop E6 first to win
that knight uh for without giving
material back so uh just to point out
the Knight often Retreats rather than
hops forward and if that's the case
white will step his own King into the
corner play Pawn to F3 and blow the
whole position open so I don't know
whose King is safer I don't know what to
make of it I've seen positions like this
before and they are always just crazy
and chances for both
sides this like to see yes it's exactly
what we like to see and I think we're
gonna see this one blow up meanwhile the
other game that needs to blow up for Yan
pishi is his one against Maxim and uh I
think it's a good moment to check in
with them because look at what we've got
on the board is definitely started from
a sicilian and now the fight for the D5
square that last move Knight to G8 it
surprises me and it looks like at least
from the eval bar that y
is on his way to make a
comeback Robert this last move Knight G8
given a cross a Miss by our harsh game
review but uh yeah it's just an ugly
position I think no good choices there
for black look at this pin it's ugly the
White Knight beautiful even if you just
cement that Knight with a move like Pawn
to C4 um how is black ever going to
break this bind looks beautiful for
white well when we have a Miss I do
think it's important to show everybody
what was the improvement over this and
it was wasn't actually pretty for black
so this this decision was made out of
several badl looking options if you take
this Knight on D5 with say your F Knight
after the pawn takes back there is a
little Fork the bishop has to take
because the Knight on E7 is pinned and
now this is where loose pieces drop off
so I do think there's a tactic that
starts with Bishop takes Pawn on G6 uh
because the bishop on D5 is loose you
take my Bishop back great for you I will
take your knight first step and then
take your Bishop on D5 and I know we
just went down to deep variation but
this is what's going on in these players
heads and what Maxim is suggesting is
that this position is beyond hope for
black the engine doesn't hate it but
practically speaking white controls all
of the key squares in the middle of the
board namely the light squares so you
have a knight that can occupy light
Square in addition to the Queen the
bishop it can't do anything about it
it's on the dark Square it's inherently
stuck to its color complex this is an
overwhelming Advantage for white I think
practically speaking white wins a
position like this a healthy uh majority
of the time and that's why Max said look
play a passive move just to avoid making
Jan's life as clear as possible I think
it's a good try in a bad position I I
think Tanya that no one would want to
play this position from Maxim's shoes
really well explained there I think from
a practical perspective what Maxim has
done he's kept maximum number of pieces
in the board it also gives white the
opportunity to go wrong but the other
position that we saw with all the trades
and the good knight wors his bad Bishop
all the weaknesses for maxim Maxim would
have been on the defensive side I'm just
thinking about the fact that this looks
like it came from some sort of a night
off that became a hybrid with a dragon
now the night off is Maxim's bread and
butter how did he manage to get into so
much trouble early on in something that
he's a big big expert
in the problem for maxim and I liked
your maximum P Tanya the problem for
maxim is he's employed the naidorf but
that was also The Stomping Ground of yan
pishi for most of his career we're
seeing the two biggest world experts uh
in the current age at least least of the
nid off the Sicilian nof and
unfortunately if your opponent knows
just as much as you do they also know
what openings you fear what variations
are the most testing most tricky and
look at this blowing open the king side
now this is a pawn Sacrifice by Yap
ponesi but he's zeroing in on this black
king he knows that this is a big Target
open lines are the currency of this
position who cares about pawns the fewer
pawns you have the more open lines you
have and uh this black king now in huge
huge trouble not much to do if you slide
your Bishop back it will simply get
traded off this Defender and if the
black Bishop disappears then black is
doomed on the G file so many targets
lined up and look at the body language
uh Robert Maxim just hating his life uh
questioning his life decisions with
Sicilian ID here I don't know about his
life but I hate his position and while
he is in the think tank trying to figure
out a way out of this I think we should
go back to our two-board view because
it's not just this game that has
fireworks the other one we knew it was
coming that it was brewing but now it's
reached that point where we look at the
right hand side of our screen it's Ali
Raza fua whose time in this tournament
is on the line the advantage according
to the evaluation is in White's favor
and I think it's easy to explain so why
don't we dive in quickly to Wesley so
with the white pieces against Ali Rea
because Wesley he's on the door of
eliminating this candidate in fuia
because the Knight on the rim is dim and
I'm not talking about the Knight on H4
which snagged the pawn I'm talking about
that on A5 that's trapped over there and
White's last move it hits a bishop yes
but also shuts down any possibility of
defending the Knight if the bishop saves
itself Queen up to B4 and I think Tanya
it's pretty clear that that Knight on
the rim it's not dim any longer it's
gone I'm just looking at this line that
you're pointing out and dasi just feels
like that Knight on A5 drops alir is
going to be down a piece so what is it
that he wants and only one thing makes
sense to me is that he wants to go all
out on the king side he wants to start
pushing his Pawn he's going to try and
come for Wesley's King clearly the eval
bar or the evil bar in this case for
alira seems to say the plan isn't
working but let's say if white was to
force this line Bishop goes back you can
capture the Knight on H4 or go directly
either ways either the Knight will fall
back or the queen will fall back and
Knight G6 here you take on A5 black
starts going H4 it at least starts to
get a bit messy on the king side with
White's Queen on the other end of the
board and maybe David you will help me
follow up with the attack like you're
showing the queen moves forward the G
Pawn pushing forward this is far from
over you're up material you might be
down a king if you're not careful on the
king
side uh certainly slightly deceptive the
evaluation bar we now know that white
should be winning with best play if you
find all the best defensive moves for
example here maybe Pawn to F4 due to a
nice little skewer on the fifth rank uh
maybe you defend here but this is rapid
chess nerves involved high stakes and uh
so hard to evaluate for the players I
think both players will probably guess
that the evaluation bars on white side
but fuja is one of the best in the world
at just hustling swindling his opponents
and he goes for it immediately not even
caring about this black Bishop he might
even be down two pieces this black
Bishop might be snacked on next the
Black Knight might disappear if the
White Queen steps forward to B4 but he's
all in it's all about the white king and
here we go it is a r material versus the
attack who is going to Wesley playing
super fast though with a couple minutes
extra on the clock Robert it just feels
like too much now especially with the
dart Square Bishop gone as well he's
following our plans this line but do you
this attack being successful how easy is
is it for Wesley to blunder here no I
don't see the huge attack that ala is
hoping for and there's also a Pawn on A7
so if you can imagine the White Queen
Landing next to the Rook on the last
rank if as long as that pawn survives it
actually remains a threat but talking
specifically about this moment here uh
ala he went for the attack he went for
an aggressive position from the black
side but that often does play to Wesley
so's favor he doesn't mind getting into
tactical positions if you're the one
initiating them often times from a
speculative decision so I think that
Wesley he's happy to be in this point he
knows that he has the upper hand he also
has more time than his opponent so what
moves come to mind well the Knight on D
is under attack right now I would even
think about giving up that Knight to win
that Knight on A5 Queen B6 for white
looks very attractive to my eyes because
black unfortunately can't combine
multiple ideas you want to both take the
Knight on D2 and push your Pawn to G3 to
trap that Bishop over there next to the
white king but you can't get away with
both and that's why I think Wesley is
just in time to keep everything
together David a really really exciting
position this one down a piece is Wesley
going to spend some time trying to
defend this Knight on D2 or will he go
for Counterattack it's quite a big
moment and I think it's really
instructive how Wesley's paused right
now he knows this is critical he has to
try to make sure nothing happens on the
king side and then he's just up
materially he takes the win he takes the
match so really important for him and he
goes for your idea Robert he's not going
to waste time defending that Knight on
D2 and I kind of like this move even a
bit more than Queen to B6 simply because
it's got one more idea you're at you're
attacking the Knight on E5 but also that
pawn on D6 whenever you can make a
multi-purpose move in chess you've got
to do it Queen B4 I like
it4 looks good double attack simply and
now fua simply has to back up those
earlier sacrifices he has to go for
Glory he plays Pawn to G3 two problems
here firstly uh White can just allow
this bishop to drop white is already a
piece up actually that will be a double
agent for example at the very minimum if
uh say I take this Pawn say I just hide
in the corner now this black pawn keeps
the white king safe it's guarding white
here actually you want to pick up this
pawn and throw it off the board uh if
you're fuia but frustratingly in chess
you cannot do that white Knights will
start coming forward the black king is
uh the one in trouble here but if we go
back to the current position other
Solutions might involve just taking this
Pawn off the board look at this if you
take this Pawn Counterattack against the
black king suddenly and it becomes a
pure race I'm not sure how you fend off
the attack against the white king this
has to be worked out really really well
but we see the evaluation bar showing
that white attack is the more dangerous
of the two I would be looking at Bishop
takes Pawn check here I'd be looking at
moves like Queen takes Pawn if you're
not getting checkmated black having
threats of his own meanwhile it's still
up in the air but if you're careful we
know that Wesley is winning this is why
he stopped to calculate he senses the
critical moment and uh whichever he goes
for whichever move now uh taking the
Knight one of the options we mentioned
he will be confident that he's worked
things out so this move given across a
uh Miss but still Advantage white and I
think now he will slide the white king
into the corner and there we go he's
given a blue arrow the only good move
use that black porn as a shield but
sufficient to maintain
white uh Robert still super complicated
do you see the time uh situation playing
a critical role I think the time will
play a part just because from my eyes
white has his Pawn on A7 there are two
distinct threats taking on F7 with check
which just wins the house and queen to
B8 and oh my goodness I forgot that
black could Castle because that King was
in the center black was going for the
attack but castling actually took care
of both problems at the same time white
is still in the driver seat look at the
positioning of each respective King
Knight F3 I don't know if that was your
arrow it's probably saying it's the only
move that keeps the advantage for white
at this stage but it's also a very
natural move so I would prefer Wesley's
chances at this stage T do you see
anything that would counter
that I'd love to find something for
black back here trying to look for ways
to compensate for uh I'm just trying to
do the math here so how many pawns is
that with that pawn on A7 it makes it
really difficult White's got a Pawn on
A7 Black's got a Pawn on H2 so even
though materially I believe this is
balanced but just simply what having the
better Pawn structure the better pieces
black king more exposed I love how black
spawn on H2 is actually defending white
King on H1 a black sking in danger it
just looks like despite not having
material advantage Wesley's got all the
p play in the position so completely
agree with you Robert that Ali Resa has
to find a way to save this one and it's
not going to be
easy my Works in that game but meanwhile
let's check out our other game where
things are really heating up uh it feels
like Wesley against alaza there will
take a Karma turn at least for the next
few moves but wow just on time a queen
sacrifice and check me coming fash gra
resigns wow we will break that down for
you a bit later but npom finishes off in
style and Strikes Back 1-1 Armageddon
guaranteed now the black king about to
be m in the next two uh wow we said it
it was oneway traffic black was
suffering on the king side rare to see
such sh flamboyant checkmating patterns
though at this high level so
congratulations to Yan
pishi yeah how do you think he's feeling
now I mean this last position with Queen
takes Pawn that we see on the left side
of our screen this looks this looks like
a massacre that just happened but from
start to finish Yan was in driver's seat
we got an armagon and the kind of games
that we've had the two decisive games
between these two we can expect a lot of
fireworks in that one but let's shift
our Focus onto Wesley versus Ali Raza
because big things are happening in that
one black has grabbed the C3 Pawn why
did just me the move that gets that gets
rewarded should I say with a question
mark and Ali razar's going all out on
the H file you to try to keep things
under control but how' you do that he
walked right into this now the queen on
C3 is in line with the White Knight on
F3 so the G2 Pawn is frozen earlier the
white Pawn was one square back so there
wouldn't have been an attack on this
Knight and if that G2 Pawn is gone the
white king will also probably leave the
board with it that attack looks too
powerful so that was a I mean I don't
know if that got the two question marks
that normally blunders get but that was
a blunder from Wesley so and his time in
this tournament might be done look at
him look at his clock look at his
position this looks
terrible just turned around in the space
of one move as you say Robert just the
fact that the black queen now has access
to the third Rank and can sneak over to
get this white king the eval bar has
dropped through the floor White's going
for a Counterattack I'm not sure what
Wesley's trying to do here he's trying
to force the issue maybe trying to take
this Pawn off the board at some point
but surely just drag the white king out
from its hiding place there we go the
white king forced forward and where the
blow there are Knight checks in the air
Black's Rook can soon slide over and uh
it feels like at the right moment the
black Bishop's going to join in the
black Queen's going to join in the White
Knight is the only piece covering the
key squares but if you find the right
ingredients in the right order this is
simply going to be Checkmate um Alara he
is so strong at attacking surely he's
going to find something but only one
minute left and Wesley now needs to just
cross his fingers hope pray this white
king is surely living its last life now
um do we see it do we see the Checkmate
uh Tanya wow Rook h8 do you approve of
this one I like it it just gets The Rook
into the attack you're threatening to
blow open with the H Pawn moving forward
Knight F4 check now will be a big big
threat perhaps the idea is to go H1
Queen White takes it with the rook and
then Knight F4 check would have been the
killer blow so vesley needs to stop the
H Pawn he uses it as a shield comes back
now the bishop joins the attack and Ali
Raza all his pieces are playing but this
is getting crazy Where is the check bait
coming in do you just we
go was Queen he gives up his Bishop then
his pass Pawn because the white king is
hunted resignation what a finish that
was sick from
Ala wow Wesley so is eliminated this is
it Ali Resa stays in the tournament he
wins a game that he was in so much
trouble but in the endend what happened
there that attack Robert I'm still
reeling in from it
Wesley was in driver's seat how did this
even happen well the tenacious defensive
resources of Ali Raza fuja you see his
score in Gold uh he feels like he just
earned himself some gold a heftier
Payday by moving on in the losers
bracket as he eliminates Wesley so the
finalist in the Champions chess tour
finals what a match that was and not to
be overlooked was the match on the left-
hand side of R screen one to one but
they were trading blows like two heavy
weights going at it I feel like we were
just treated to some spectacular
chests that was an insane insane round I
think we had two checkmates in both
these games and David I know there's so
much to show out of these games because
both were big tactical fights but you've
got to take us through where it all
turned around and the Beautiful Finish
that we just witnessed let's do it
lightning struck twice two checkmates to
decide those two games and with a twist
this time let's check out those uh those
finales in the chess browser powered by
Opera and first of all let's start with
Yan Naomi with white against Maxi VRA
the black king now in huge huge trouble
white pieces lined up look at the
battery of the White Queen and Rook
especially on the H file instead though
Knight E7 check first to kick this black
king into the corner and now lining up
Bishop to G5 A P sacrifice allowing the
bishop to drop with check but the white
king slides to the opposite corner this
time safe and after Quin to G3 the
Beautiful Finish the check mating
pattern Queen takes H6 do your puzzle
Rush everyone because this is beautiful
if black had taken this Queen off the
board another check and now White's
three pieces and porn combined to trap
the black king a wonderful finish there
from yanomi and uh I think if possible
we can just switch over to the other
game where uh the other Checkmate was
equally beautiful from Ala fua but maybe
that's one to show later as uh first I
just wanted to mention if any of you
want to go and check out that Opera
browser yourself at home then uh it's
available on Windows Mac and Android and
it can be integrated directly into your
sidebar so for those of you like me who
love playing Blitz at home uh with the
boss not looking then uh Opera it's for
you just make sure you don't get fired
because J can be super addictive check
out the Opera brow browser we've got a
big Armageddon coming up to check out
who goes through in the bracket who gets
eliminated stay with us don't go
anywhere we'll be back with the
[Music]
bids
[Applause]
[Music]
every
well hey everyone we're here at the
chess.com Champions chess tour finals
and of course Fair Play is a huge topic
for everyone around the world as it
should be including questions like can
you actually keep a venue secure can you
actually stop cheating even if it's some
of the most advanced spyware level stuff
out there the answer answer is yes you
can and where I just entered is where
the players enter they can go directly
to their rooms and back from here but
now we're going to walk through as if
we're a regular person this guy's going
to say you don't belong here but okay
Jokes Aside all right now we're going to
get into the real stuff all right
players are brought down into this area
before games at a scheduled time so that
they have enough time to be fully
checked for fair play this right here is
the private Lounge area where only staff
are allowed to have Electronics the
players are not allowed to have any
Electronics with them once they've
entered this area but when they come
early they do so because they need
plenty of time to get fully checked by
our fair play Tech I'll try to talk a
little softare cuz they're actually
playing their games right now but okay
at some point here a player will come
over and they'll wait in this line
before being asked to enter the private
fairplace screening area once we're in
this private fairplace screening area
the players wait only one player in here
at a time I'm standing here right next
to a sir who looks like he has a fancy
device what's your name sir my name is
George I work with the Fairplay
Department my job is to uh detect
cheaters is to find out if anyone is
trying to get a gadget that helps him
win the game that's not going to happen
on my watch not going to happen on his
watch okay but all right this is a
little bit fancier than the normal kind
of thing you see in rfg scanner what
exactly is this is this doing that's
different it's called a nonlinear
Junction detector its job is to detect
any signal signals transmitted from
another device outside or transmitted
from a device that is on a player who's
trying to cheat outside to a uh foreign
sender it can only be acquired from
specific countries it's not like a
normal metal detector that you just buy
on eBay it's a microphone I guess I
don't even know why we're doing this I'm
full of the things that are going to get
detected I didn't actually hide anything
here which is good to know maybe I
should have but okay we're going to find
out we'll see that's right don't assume
anything it's pretty phenomenal stuff
thank you George this is pretty much
just a bunch of cameras for the show we
do have cameras every where so we're
watching The Players no matter what now
after they've been scanned they are not
allowed to leave this area like period
during active gameplay so you're talking
about an area that is maybe more secure
than any over theboard chess tournament
that has ever been secured that's what
you're talking about right and I hope
that watching this video showed you what
we're doing I hope you appreciate it
it's some pretty high level stuff I
definitely am making a call to every
over theboard organizer to invest in
their own nonlinear Junction detection
devices cuz at this point if you're not
doing that you're not doing it good
enough and we hope that you will
consider investing in the same way that
chess.com has we
out
and just before our break we saw an
explosive Checkmate from Al ala fua
against Wesley so and we just wanted to
break it down in uh slower time here the
big mistake by Wesley so opening up the
third rank for the black queen was
terminal but the punishment was
spectacular Pawn H3 here from fuia
zeroing in on this white king in the
corner look how it was dragged out into
the open and then checkmated the White
Knight left forward to G5 but after a
capture Rook to h8 it looked like the
white king had found safety Refuge yet
again in the corner but no the bishop
jumped out to H3 L it looked like white
was suddenly getting chances a
Counterattack against the black king but
instead Bishop to G2 one of the moves of
the day so far just forcing the white
king out into the open Forest second
time not just that black makes a new
Queen sacrificing the beautiful pride
and joy of his position that pawn with
the idea that if Rook takes Queen Knight
to F4 is a check there's nowhere for the
white king to go no safe squares other
than the back rank but once you Retreat
suddenly Queen takes rook and this is
mate the white king now caught on its
back rank Spectacular from fuia a pawn
sacrifice a bishop sacrifice his whole
castle was burning there but he got the
enemy King this was spectacular and uh
remember if you want to check out Opera
yourselves then it also has cool
features built in like a VPN a browser
Ai and platforms like WhatsApp Tik Tok
are also integrated right into the
browser sidebar so fantastic play by
Foria and hopefully more of the same in
the upcoming
Armageddon indeed David there's a big
Armageddon coming up wesly so has been
eliminated and one of these two players
will be eliminated and our bids are in
Maxim VRA wins the bid with 6 minutes 53
seconds yishi bidding 7 minutes and 30
seconds Yan will start with the white
pieces Maxim starts with 6 minutes 53
seconds on the clock starts with black
but a draw means that Maxim wins the
match Yan has to win with white David
the players are ready to go what do you
make if the bids is Yan does Yan's bid
imply that he was happy with the white
pieces does seem to look that way it's
always hard to know in Armageddon it's
always about emotions who's Riding High
I mean I wouldn't be surprised if Yan
after that fantastic experience of
delivering Checkmate the queen sacrifice
that he just wants to get right back in
there more of the same a repeat but uh
he knows it's not going to be as easy
second time round and in Armageddon
there's that extra flavor of uh kind of
needing to win at all costs it adds a
bit of pressure um so Yan feeling
confident riding a high but Maxim it's
up to him to do something different E4
will we see another night off Robert wow
apparently we have seen a night off an
aggressive opening and for Max I think
he's also happy to have the black pieces
after all yesterday he couldn't get
anything going against Dennis lazic so
now we have the start of a sicilian
where the players are playing for
different ideas we don't have a
symmetrical Pawn structure the Kings
have yet to Castle and curious moment
for Yan to pause Tanya I'm surprised
that he's spending time but the good
news is he has time to use because of
his bid yeah absolutely and the two
decisive games that they had in the
rapid both were won by white the last
game played night off by Maxim Vash lra
did not go too well but it kind of was
like a hybrid with Maxim going with G6
Bishop G7 he's doing none of that like
you said this is a more strategic night
off the fight will be around the D5
square and as soon as I say strategic
the H Pawn is up the board throw that
strategy out of it out of the window
we've got fireworks already H4 coming in
what do we make of this uh wow but he
goes with Development
David it feels a bit inconsistent from
Maxim Vash gra he said a he threw the
black H Pawn down the board but he
didn't say B he didn't kick this white
knight away maybe reluctant to drive the
White Knight forward into this F5 square
and uh watch out for him if he gets time
black to control the Knight by putting a
Pawn on G6 dominating this Ste on G3 it
is a target um it's just about whether
npom nesi ends up having to retreat this
night or leaping forward if he can jump
forward successfully he will do it he
will love life but if he needs to
retreat not a good sign for white and
look at the clock situation Maxim's been
so Speedy Max of opening preparation um
Nomi on the other hand much much slower
and with the white king castle on this
flank it means we will not see a repeat
of that earlier game no big big attacks
against the black king which is yet to
declare its intent Robert definitely an
upgrade uh considering the previous game
for Vash gra well it couldn't get any
worse that's for sure he was blown off
the board he was moving his Knights to
their starting squares but one of the
big questions about this position and in
any night knorf is can black
successfully play the move D6 to D5
because that D6 Pawn it's a backwards
Pawn that white wants to barrel down on
and if you could play D5 the good news
is you get rid of that potential
weakness you open up a diagonal for your
dark squore Bishop in particular but you
also maybe leave some vulnerable pawns
behind namely the E5 Pawn which can
become a Target so these are the central
questions and speaking of central
squares Knight to D5 giving up a pawn
temporarily wow what's the followup here
because loose pieces drop off and yet
Yan has not made his move wow tactics
already yeah David already I was about
to say that tactics on the board uh and
you said a pawn sacrifice and he picks
up the H5 Pawn so a temporary one but
the computer thear does not like it
what's wrong with Knight takes pawn it
looks like the most natural move to
me it's simp that that pawn wasn't
actually too relevant in the position if
anything it's helped black a bit like
that fuia game with the Checkmate
getting rid of your pawns open up opens
up lines for your own attack look at
this black Rook now poised and uh the
bishop also on this diagonal the white
king is not feeling comfortable at all
right now it's also cost white two whole
Tempe two moves to go forward with the
Knight and then Retreat to take this
pawn and uh if you compared the quality
just a few moves ago of the white E Pawn
versus the black H Pawn no way should
you trade a Central Pawn for a flank
Pawn like that opening up your
opponent's Rook so I think just a step
in the wrong direction a misevaluation
by aoni he's not dead it's not over but
wow quein to C8 he's lining up big
threats this Arrow isn't mine but
White's only good move according to the
computer at least Bishop takes G6 but
look out if uh you don't take this Pawn
for black to strike on G2 the black
queen is actually lining up against this
H3 Square as well all hell is broken
loose it's chaos on the board Robert
help me through how should aom even
start trying to calculate this position
well I think that the reason why Bishop
takes G6 even works is it looks like
black is going to do the same thing one
of the big Ideas is a sacrifice in front
of the white king with Bishop takes G2
but that white Bishop it can slide back
now that there's no G6 Pawn anymore and
in fact white wins this game because the
queen is kicked off the diagonal and the
H3 Pawn is defended so this is a big
tactical opportunity for Yan in fact we
see it on the board but look at what
Maximus responded with Knight D4 Bishop
takes G2 doesn't work but it might work
on the next turn that is the threat the
G6 Bishop is hanging and while the
engine can be critical of the objective
evaluation when all you need is a draw
if this can force the draw you're happy
to play in this style I think that the
white king is very vulnerable Tanya I
don't know if you're with me here but
how could you play this way from the
white side it looks too dangerous this
is terrifying for white and I absolutely
love Maxim's last move jumping in with
that Knight to D4 he barely took any
time to make that move now the bishop on
G6 is hanging because the D5 Bishop
doesn't hang anymore you've taken
control of the F5 Square so as you
pointed out Bishop takes G2 is a massive
threat right now not just that also
watch out if you were to play a move
like Bishop H5 trying to block out the
hline trying to fight the threat of
Bishop takes pawn bishop takes G2 the C2
Pawn will be hanging then the queen on
C8 the Knight on D4 all lined up
attacking the C2 Pawn you might fight on
the king side but your queen side sides
falling apart Knight D4 is a star move
and Yana pesi is in big trouble David
totally agreed there's so many threats
he's trying to neutralize the threats
Now by trading pieces a good move good
classical wisdom from Yan pomi uh again
this Arrow indicating that black should
be trading pieces off and he does so uh
remember everyone at home if you're
being attacked trade pieces trade Queens
just try to survive the downside as
Tanya pointed out you're losing a pawn
now simply uh this Pawn C2 you were for
for a moment a pawn ahead but that is a
valuable Pawn white is stuck with these
three flank pawns which are going to
take an age to ever March up the board
but watch out for black Central pawns to
connect and dominate the whole Midfield
the whole Center of uh the
board this is just uh oneway traffic
considering he just needs a draw this is
a dream for Vash gra he's not only
survived the opening uh Not only was he
asking the questions he's head on the
clock now and he's got the advantage on
the board why not push push forward for
Glory yeah
and Robert I didn't even realize the
clock I mean this is crazy Yana bash is
the one who had more time to stop with
now he's behind on the clock it looks
like Maxim has managed to pick up all
the central pawns giving up his FR flank
pawns the D Pawn is moving forward how
do you see Yan fighting this one how
does he keep the game going and that's
what he needs to do I don't have an
answer specifically but generally he
needs to keep the game going and try to
get a mutual time scramble because
that's the way he comes back in this
position he needs to win he doesn't need
to equalize because let's say the way to
equalize is trading off the all the
pieces and shaking hands making a draw a
draw is a loss for the player with the
white pieces in Armageddon so how do you
stir up some trouble I don't think you
rush it a lot of people think when they
have to win they just go all in for an
attack they sacrifice pieces here you
just need to keep the game going somehow
because white has an outside pass Pawn
this H3 Pawn so in certain end games
that can be at the minimum of a decoy or
at the best it can become a passer and
hard
stop for white right now but I love I've
got to say what Maxim is doing central
control uh these pawns control
everything they dominate the board and
uh he's also marched his King out into
the center we normally say don't try
this at home but with Queens off the
board you're unlikely to get checkmated
now knowing that a draw is sufficient
he's aiming to trade off the Rooks this
was shut down but uh watch out for these
pawns advancing I also love the fact
that the king is going to support the
pawns uh the pawns are the pride of
enjoy here the foot soldiers but the
king is going to support them and uh
just enforce their Advance inexorably
towards the the promotion squares and
look at this they're just going to
Steamroller everything in their way the
white Bishops now lost two full Tempe
the black king is going to come I'm
itching for this move the black F Pawn's
going to roll and uh I just don't see
anything for white to hope for here not
just that but he's reminding the white
king that on these lines look at this
the two black Rooks still poised just in
case uh you let your guard slip so right
now Vash gra It Feels Like Only the
clock or a blunder can trip him up four
minutes Robert you mentioned the time
situation lack of
increment it's going to become a race at
some point um do you think the
position's easy natural enough for Vash
to play Under time well a lot of his
moves have been easy to this point but
look what's happening and look at the
evaluation bar the king is in the center
Bishop H4 not an accurate response and
this white knight that was sitting on G3
it can hop forward E4 maybe to C5 the
center might collapse at any moment so
Tanya as I look at this position and wow
he takes a step back which actually is
the better option I think that it's
Maxim who needs to prove that he can
stabilize here because his King is in
worst
shape yeah because it just felt like you
come back with the Knight you're
actually inviting Black's ewn to move
forward and Maxim doesn't make the move
I think he's calculating what happens
after white gives a couple of checks F5
comes to mind if you go forward with the
King to E5 perhaps Bishop f four check
is the big threat watch out that D4 Pawn
is hanging with the Knight and the Rook
on D1 lined up so decision to be made in
the center by Maxim and it's not an easy
one he is going down on the clock once
again for Yana pishi there is a minute
up right now it's going to be a big
scramble it's going to be about who's
got the faster Mouse skills talking
about that what do we know about these
two players who's faster on the mouse
right now David I think they're equally
fast both are super Speedy Vash Gra he's
on form he's so instinctive but he's
lost his rhythm he didn't keep things
simple and your idea now on the board
Tanya and the evaluation bar rising in
White's favor he over complicated it he
was trying to win King of the Hill
something we discussed yesterday but
this king's just walked into the lion's
den it's now a clear Target this Pawn
attacked three times due to the pin and
uh for black you're struggling to hold
everything together uh moves come to
mind like dropping the bishop back to F6
to defend this Pawn but suddenly there
are other threats this check is going to
hit the black king again do due to the
pin cannot be captured and wh Knight is
going to soon snack on this Central Pawn
multiple threats Vash gravy's lost
control on both board and clock down to
two minutes he didn't keep things simple
he didn't trade off pieces he went for
the attack himself and uh he let things
slip and now okay attacking the Knight
but a check this Pawn surely is going to
drop off he's holding things together
with his King this is the bravest King
I've seen in a long time well it gets an
exclamation point it was the best move
and white is just a couple coordin moves
away from winning that E4 Pawn as you
said not so easy and say look at the
clocks Ian white is well ahead but look
at this last move the evaluation bar it
keeps going up and down this is the
clear best move and there there was no
other choice and as we look at the
scorecard beneath the board both players
have made a couple questionable
decisions but they also keep finding
these only moves when they must and for
Maxim in particular that's important
because he is the one who has to defend
his King is in the open ananya people
like to think Queens are off the board
it's an end game this is a queenless
middle game a Checkmate could happen
especially against that black
king Yi has been on the receiving end of
a checkmate with the king in the center
against Jose Martinez he might be the
one delivering it today as well and we
see that the Bishop from H4 H4 has been
pushed back but as long as the E4 and
the D3 Pawn remain alive for maxim that
gives Maxim a lot of chances so Yan
hasn't been successful in grabbing one
of these two pawns we're seeing
inaccuracies but you can't blame the
players for that they're no increment
it's high tension high pressure the
loser of this match gets eliminated out
of the cheser bble Masters anything can
happen but I'm loving those two pawns
it's Advantage Max teim right
now oh those are the strongest pawns
you'll ever see not just the bravest
King you'll ever see leading from the
front leading his Army to victory and uh
this looked a dangerous move for black
because this walks into a check a skewer
and this Pawn drops but after a check
the black king simply steps out the way
and actually we're going to see this
play out on on the board the black
Bishop's ready to poach on this Knight
as well and actually the more pieces
disappear now the quicker the kind of
safer it becomes as well and um yeah I
think he's going to at least bag the
draw here at the very minimum I was
going to say take off that night was
this a mouse slip he's trying to remove
the bishop instead given a question mark
a bit of a mysterious move that because
now white blocks and suddenly the black
king is under Fire again suddenly Pawn
to B3 is going to be a nasty check this
one's turning it's the time it's the
clock situation that's going to inside
this game a minute up for Nomi and a
pawn up now on the board blacks porns
suddenly uh unable to progress mistakes
come in pairs and sorry T I was just
going to say that several mistakes in a
row from Maxine V including this last
move to take this Knight on C3 it was
David's idea before but T it's a bit too
late at this stage because what you
really wanted was to force Yan to take
it with the pawn I thought he was going
to grab it with the bishop but Yan
anyways takes it with the pawn now again
we saw the IAL bar not approve of that
the night is jumping and it's coming on
to C4 to start targeting that uh
blockade on D2 right now Rook takes Pawn
is the big threat which doesn't allow
Maxim to jump in just yet Maxim's got to
rush he's touching the one minute Mark
there is no increment this will come
down to
flagging this position is one where
there's a pass Pawn on D3 white is up a
pawn but black has the most impressive
one and you see the last couple moves
from black they are great decision and
another exclamation point given this
Rook can go up to C4 maybe over to A4
it's just venturing forward and causing
problems white finally is pushing a pawn
but G4 now is loose in addition to the
Rook going to the queen side so with so
much pressure with so much on the line
for Yap pami things are going wrong on
that fourth rank as black finally is
active so black is active but white now
putting his King on the edge of the
board this is counter intuitive he's
trying to set a trap do not take this
Pawn with the black Rook because uh
suddenly the White Knight
sorry the white Rook would have
eliminated the Black Knight and white
would have trapped the opponent instead
he's aiming to remove the defender white
Rook if it's traded off can no longer
prevent the advance of this D Pawn it's
going to be a race but it looks like
black is simply ahead Black's Pawn too
close to touchdown the Knight is coming
the king is coming but a mistake Now by
Vash gra White's pawns are running
suddenly Whit's ahead and that's the
point the King was needed to stop those
pawns and Maxim V lra reacts he knows he
missed this idea yeah naushi is back in
the game all Maxim had to do was jump in
with the Knight to attack the bishop but
he's one move too late can white just
continue marching down the board with
the G Pawn ignore the bishop hanging on
D2 Robert you absolutely can as you see
those arrows that is what white should
do you can also first move the bishop
back to safety but look at the
evaluation bar to the left of the board
look at the trajectory the game beneath
the board it was white being worse then
white being better then suddenly White's
completely winning after black was
winning the advantage has exchanged
hands unfortunately it's not changing
anymore white is winning two pass pawns
are better than
one and now Max K King David has to fall
back but it's too late and that's it
Maxim VRA resigns the gon is Unstoppable
Maxim is eliminated Yi with a big turn
around takes the match wow David just
unbelievable what we just w
crazy stuff so many turns around uh
turnarounds we said it Maxine played a
great game he was so brave with his King
but ultimately the clock situation
punished him one slip and it was all
over and he is out of the chess bow
Masters Maxim V lra and Wesley so have
been eliminated Yan neishi and ala fuja
continue their run what an Armageddon
that was an absolute roller coaster
Robert hot breaking for maxim it's going
to hurt it's really going to sting and
as you see Yap pal she becomes the
second player who is already locked in
to the losers quarterfinal it probably
should have been Maxim Basher lra at
least that's how he feels but that was
Steely determination from yapishi he
never caved and he actually created
complications where it looked like they
didn't exist so Ali Raza fua he earned
his match Victory after a slip from
Wesley so yand pomi did much of the same
it looked like the other players were
going to get the job done but that's
what happens in these quicker time
controls in a Flash did the advantages
change hands so unpredictable this new
top time format this season on the
Champions chess tour we saw two of the
most beautiful checkmates you'll ever
see and ultimately it was those two
players who deliver the checkmates who
progress and will be gaining confidence
every single round they lived life on
the edge I'm going to say both players
really playing fast and loose there with
their pieces But ultimately rewarded for
their courage and commiserations to the
others who eliminated they 'll be back
later this season wow just complete
turnaround at the end in both those
matches Ali are surviving a big scare
against Wesley so it looked like Wesley
had the win in his hand and then that
turned around and here it looked like it
was going to be Maxim who makes it
through and then it turns around it has
been a shocking dramatic start here at
the chessable Masters but of course
that's not the only chess we've got some
great news uh for all of you watching
your regular colit chess league matches
they're returning next Saturday on
February the 10th Mark the date it's
10th of February tune in for exciting
team chess matchups between top
university level talents with commentary
from ccl's Jolie and the one and only
Anna crumbling will be back use the
command CCL in chat for everything you
need to
[Music]
know and of course we will be back for
more as the day is just started while it
has been the end of the road for maxim
Yana pishi goes through the battle
continues in the winners bracket we will
be back in just a few don't go anywhere
as Magnus and Company will be playing
more
[Music]
chess
take
day
[Music]
welcome everyone to the first ever
chess.com holiday party we're here with
the eight well seven of the Champions
chess tour finalists one of them is not
here but lucky for us as Santa I already
knew that one of the gifts might come in
in real handy so what we've got here is
a uh is a gift that keeps on giving for
some lucky lady out there right there
we're going to put Magnus right here in
between Maxine and Hikaru but let me
explain the rules real quick we have
eight numbers in here everyone here is
going to pick a number to decide the
order in which they go to choose the
presents in front the present can be
stolen if you like what someone else
gets you don't even have to to pick a
present you can just steal their present
from them but once the present has been
stolen twice it is officially frozen you
can never steal that present again at
the end of the game whichever one of you
gets the number one gets to choose
whether to keep your present or make one
final steal to get the gift you want so
I'm going to go around
here I'm going to take the last number
lot like our fair play you know judge
jury and executioner over here right hey
there you go insert joke who's number
one okay Maxine bash the gr starts us
off let's do it well I guess this hor my
guess look at that I know what you guys
thought you guys thought you were
showing up and every gift was going to
be a joke no it Nots that's a Nintendo
switch M play that every day I'm Number
Two okay I have the the best number the
worst number wor are that worse than
eight oh eight is the second best oh
really yeah cuz eight you get to have
all the information thank you I got a
box what's in the box I have a smaller
box I got airpods wow oh sweeter every
white elephant has to have an ugly
Christmas sweater and you're the one who
got it okay all right who's four
[Laughter]
okay you can cook the
knife Denis here we go okay it says
magnet
show it to the camera the proud owner
all right the car is shaking shaking vag
or is he
stealing who with that
Danny that was not my idea all I'm going
to to use this one here certificate of
disposition and Proclamation lord of the
bong Cloud opening okay I'm I'm a lord
of the bong Cloud okay here we go Wesley
I'm steal yeah yeah it's hard to choose
I see I see fa's airpods that's fair
okay airpods have been stolen it's
official game on so we have to keep the
game going so I'm taking your all
right okay he's rolling the dice he
loves a n that much okay Dennis you've
been set free oh you got the switch okay
Dennis lvic officially owns the switch
part and thr the night I guess I'm
taking these he taking the airod airpods
are off the table which means Wesley you
have the the power to choose a new gift
oh my gosh what is it are you
kidding oh yeah you're paying right yeah
that's the okay I'll keep it okay there
we go that's it and that everyone was
our first ever white
elephant
he's down a piece he's down two pawns a
couple of checks magnus's King is going
to dance easily out of them take my
queen and give me a new one please he's
losing now he walked right into the and
they know it they know it turn your
boards 909 952 made a big mistake oh and
the bar is going up this is an absolute
Gem of a game Wesley saw has done it
he's going for the attack but he's
walked into checkm black can play Rook
takes
porn one move Checkmate two second oh my
God what arm we
in the 2021 World Blitz champion and the
2023 Champions chestor runner up Maxim R
lra and Wesley so have both been
eliminated of the ches bable Masters Yan
naishi alira fuja advaned through into
the losers quarterfinals and now it's
time for our big winner semi-finals
matchup we've got two underdogs fighting
each other the two big story lines
Dennis lasic and josim Jose Martinez
with fantastic performances they will
play against each other one will go down
to the losers bracket and of course the
reigning tour Champion Magnus Carlson
will take on big fish F which match up
are you most excited about David
they're both juicy but I've got to go
for Magnus Carlson against fed it's two
of the best rapid players in the world
as evidenced by the world rapid
championship at the end of 2023 yes the
underdog fight is going to be
fascinating as well but I can't wait to
see how fed tries to work his way around
magnificent Magnus um it's going to be
one to watch it's really hard to pick
one out of these two uh Robert but I'm
going to put you on another spot here
Dennis Laz taking on Jose Martinez now
Dennis in the last two days has taken
down Hikaru Nakamura Anish giri Maxim
Vash lra he is on some of the best chess
that he's ever played and Jos bam Jose
Martinez what a performance he had in
the plays then he takes on Yana pishi so
he's someone you can't write off Robert
is there a favorite in this one who do
you think will take it away we've got
two players on an absolute Terror Jose
Martinez to a left hand side of her
screen he just celebrated his 25th
birthday by winning the play Then making
his way to division one where he beat
Yan the pomi a day ago and the right
hand side of her screen we have Dennis
the Menace Dennis lavic who took down as
you said Hikaru Nakamura anise giri and
then yesterday Maxim vasher grv three of
the best players on the planet so I
started today with a reference to Alicia
Keys and her song Underdog go Google
that listen to that song I don't know
how to pick between these two and just
like Alicia Keys I'll root for them all
this is going to be an absolute great
clash between players with very
different styles Jose he likes to get
down to the waiting second he's a speed
demon with accuracy and I think that
Dennis has the superior openings between
these two he's a classically trained
player but he's only 17 so it's a bit
odd to see him play alongside some of
his
contemporaries yeah really interesting
The Clash of styles that they bring as
well as as you mentioned the Precision
of Jose Martinez in those seconds we've
seen him take those those Dynamic
decisions and it will be fed as well
who'll have to take some big decisions
on his board he will have to make the
most of any opportunity that presents
himself because he's up against Magnus
Carlson David break down this matchup
for us where do you see Fed should rely
on his
chances FV has to make it messy simply
uh both players the can do everything
both players love the end game they love
kind of outmaneuvering their opponents
as the material dwindles away but I do
feel fed's best chance is in that deep
dark Forest H he needs to strike again
we've said it before while Magnus isn't
quite warmed up Magnus did beat Wesley
so yesterday but he wasn't quite at his
magnificent best it felt like he's just
still moving through the gears ped has
has played a bit more chess in recent
days especially at this time format so
make things messy try to attack Magnus
if you can do not get bugged down into a
long strategic fight it will not end
well uh in the meantime though Magnus
does start with white so first job for
fed survive the first game then you can
think about maneuvering the opponent
when you have white in the
next it's a really good point starting
with the black Pieces Just make sure no
disaster strikes early and you alluded
to M Tal's Forest of complication where
the part out is wide enough for just one
player so try to make the water muddy
try to get him into messy situations
Robert do you agree that that is F's
best chance here tried to get as much
chaos in well I think for fedos he is a
combative player by nature but it can
backfire and look at this he plays the
Petro defense from the black side which
I think is a good choice against Magnus
because Magnus Carlson is the better
player that's clear but what fedos where
he can backfire is just like against ala
fua in that fourth game he was lost
right he was down a couple pawns but in
the time scramble is where he was able
to shine so I think that fedos he needs
to keep the games going going Magnus is
a brilliant speed chest player he's won
the speed chest Championship he made it
to the finals of the bullet Chess
Championship but that's where he has the
most opportunity to go wrong late stag
of the game when you don't have enough
time so I think that fedos he chose a
wise opening in game
one times have changed when I was young
okay Magnus there a bit distracted maybe
closing the curtains but when I was
young this opening if anyone played uh
This Way against the Petro trying to
trade off Queens early we would have
laughed them out of Chess we would have
told them this isn't the game for you
you know you're too timid nobody likes
players who play for a draw but Magnus
plays this type of position for a win
it's so symmetrical but white has two
extra Tempe for now and it's all about
placing the pieces on their best squares
yes the Queens have gone I I guess
Magnus is simply arguing that there's
enough forces there's enough of his army
left to cause some problems later he's
beaten the likes of yand pomi before in
this typee of position but I'm still
skeptical uh
Magnus why why not entertain us we want
to see more checkmates but fed he's
going to emerge unscathed from the
opening and uh the battle's really going
to be postponed towards the end game now
uh Robert surprised at all uh are you Es
skaing as me maybe I'm being a bit too
harsh about this opening choice I was
surprised but I think there's fos
playing something that he doesn't always
Trot out so I think that Magnus Carlson
as you said he likes getting positions
where there isn't so much risk he can
outplay his opponent and we saw just
before the latest move that the draw
rate was through the roof so Tanya when
the history shows that black can hold on
quite frequently I think players they
think let's go for that but against
Magnus Carlson it's a totally different
game absolutely agree with you this is a
queenless middle game while there is a
an obvious but a big threat on the board
immediately by Magnus that Knight
jumping in Knight takes C7 so it's
something that you need to take care of
immediately he falls back with the
bishop and yes uh the the Queens are off
the board but the gloves are still on
because I think the players want to
still fight it out Magnus we've seen him
do crazy things in the end game so I'm
still expecting this to be a fight he's
fighting for more space right now uh
it's going to be a battle it's going to
be a slow one but we've got a game on
our hands it's far from over when you're
playing against Magnus I think it only
gets scarier when the Queens are
off I'm inclined to agree I've suffered
so many times at the hands of Magnus I
think we all have at this point uh once
the Queens off he knows better than
anyone he just has this feel of where
the pieces belong he spins his web and
uh sooner or later it does get tactical
it does sharpen up and then he takes his
chances I've got to say he's handled
this really well no Witnesses at all in
the black Camp Black's King is castled
The Rook will slide across to E8 it's
just about how white develops the pieces
the white king needs to choose a side
maybe it'll sit in the center but I
don't see why black should ever be worse
you kick back the White Knight you
develop your own pieces uh this should
be level with equal play it's just about
whether Magnus can uh exert that magic a
bit later um without meaning to be too
pessimistic about this game should we
check out the opening the early stages
of the other battle The Clash of The
Underdogs Jose Martinez against Dennis
lazovic that one still early doors as
well but uh okay looks like a quiet
variation of the Spanish um very
symmetrical there as well Robert uh what
do you make of that
opening who's it going to favor on the
left hand side of our screen we see a
position with no pawns have left the
board only a pair of knights for each
side so it's a slow start for both of
these games uh both uh matches I think
they're just settling in without
creating any major threats and Dennis
lavic uh he has the black piece in this
game he is incredibly difficult to
defeat not only yesterday when he
outlasted Maxim Vash in Armageddon by
having having a position that was never
worse from the black side but I remember
in the 2023 season he played a match
against Sam Sean who's about super Grand
Master one of the best players in the
United States and they drew 12 games in
a row all right he just doesn't lose no
matter who he's playing so it's a a rare
sight for him to actually get in trouble
because he's so solid and it's no
surprise to me in this game Tanya that
Jose he is thinking trying to come up
with some ideas that give him advantage
and den is is saying no you're not going
to get that because because I am one of
the most grounded players in the
planet yes I think it's so important for
Jose to try to just keep as many pieces
on the board try and get Dennis low on
the clock but Dennis so far has been
doing great he's got about a minute and
a half Advantage there I think the one
spot where perhaps Jose would have a
better chances if it becomes a true time
scrumble we've seen Jose do amazing
things which is seconds on the clock
meanwhile in the previous season we saw
Dennis go down on the clock and struggle
in those sit situations especially if
the position was still complicated
Dennis has great endgame technique Jose
meanwhile he seems to really Thrive when
there are complications and less time on
the clock so this is going to go down to
those seconds who's got those extra
seconds when there's a Time scramble
it's still far off from now a really
level start right now I'm already
looking at ideas for Jos Pim can he try
and go all out can he try and strike in
the center there are two breaks that
come to my mind Robert D4 or F4 is this
something that black needs to keep an
eye out on for sure and I just want to
point out you called him josam and some
be like who's josam I don't see any Jos
here Jose is a streamer he's a content
creator and that is his online handle so
uh well I agree with you David I'm gonna
throw it to you because I'm not sure
what white should aim for is it going to
be D4 is it going to be F4 how are you
opening up this position or
D5 I think the answer is neither after
Dennis lack's last move uh Tanya your
idea scared Dennis so much that he
decided to strike first and why not if
you are able to set up a strong Pawn
Center like this with either color
normally you're the one holding the key
to the center uh you're the one who
decides when to trade off later U it's
up to Dennis when to take this Pawn in
the center but first of all okay a trade
there White's Knight was too strong on
F5 could not be tolerated and now white
has the bishop pair so uh I'm liking
Black's Pawn Center but I'm liking the
potential of these white Bishops
especially if White gets one or two more
moves is able to Unleash the Beast and
uh this bishop and Queen on the same
diagonal check mating threats in the air
not right now but Dennis has to watch
out for that uh first I'm expecting him
to just continue in his trademark style
Dennis lazic improve his pieces bring
all the pieces to the party nice
coordination and that's why he very
rarely loses games he doesn't leave any
structural weaknesses ever I very rarely
see him with doubled pawns for example
and he nearly never has bad pieces
either so yes white has the longer term
advantage of the Bishops but uh I think
he's doing
every um Robert how should uh Jose start
playing now what would give white reason
for
optimism well I I'm not entirely sure
and I don't think Jose knows what to do
either he is below on the clock and as
you were pointing out when you have
Bishops you want open space open
diagonals but any pawn move or capture
it leaves either a square or potential
weakness behind we did just see that
exchange of in the center black can take
back pretty much with any of the three
pieces that can take on D5 but it's also
this bishop on C7 who that may get an
open diagonal in the future if black
continues to push in the center so I
love this from Dennis Tanya he takes
with the pawn on D5 that would have been
my first instinct do you like the Pawns
in the center or the fact that white can
challenge them I like the Pawns in the
center I think they control not only the
squares like C4 and E4 but also give
black more space once the E Pawn might
move forward in a certain time the
bishop and C7 will open up the D Pawn
might move forward at the right time
opening up the dile it's just more
flexibility look at that the queen and
the bishop are already lining up there
are threats along the diagonal E4 is
something that white always has to watch
out for I think C takes D5 is uh is a
choice that a lot of us would also make
intuitively in this position what do you
think David is that uh is that a
recapture that would have been your
choice as well definitely I think these
top players the reason they're so good
and the reason they're able to get so
many wins in Rapid is because they're
always looking for the most ambitious
move and um Dennis he had to play some
solid uh choices earlier he had to give
up his light Square Bishop for a knight
but now he's playing ambitious chess
he's lined up his Rooks look at those
pieces he's lined up the queen and
Bishop yes they're not going anywhere
now but more importantly he's got the
Pawns in the center what to do next is
anyone's guess who knows has become very
uh strategic very KY it's about when one
of the sides decides to push in the
center Pawn D4 for black pawn to D4 for
white is going to be the key as well but
um I like the way that Dennis has
handled this so far I think he needs to
keep pieces on Bishop's gaining power
especially the bishop pair together uh
the kind of deeper you get into a game
the more the board clears up but uh for
now everything under control and uh yeah
Robert I think the clock situation as
well we mentioned it Dennis he's doing
everything right he's keeping his time
Advantage essential long term in this uh
match as a strategy and he's keeping the
tension alive I think he can continue to
opt for improving moves I would
potentially double Rooks on the E file
waiting before I decide to push a pawn
and create new tension so Dennis he has
several options Queen C6 also looks very
smart because it opens up new avenues
maybe Pawn to D4 for black the bishop on
C2 is a loose piece and the white king
may not feel fully safe if that diagonal
opens so both sides are trying to figure
out which diagonals they can operate on
it's not entirely clear although I think
what is clear is if you give white one
free move it's going to be a skewer and
a win of a rook for Bishop so I mean
this is a great play very precise play
from both both these players and Tanya I
think in both of our boards we just are
seeing quiet little moves improving
decisions but very sturdy from all four
of these winner
semi-finalists yes and I really like
that Dennis has parried that threat with
an active move Rook to E6 also
controlling the sixth rank we might see
The Rook Shuffle on to the king side it
also takes control of this A6 stopping
that white Pawn from moving forward on
the left side of our screen just a
simple Harmony in Black's position on
Dennis's board I like the way he's
placed the pieces and there is this
incredible maturity in his play that
I've seen I've seen it in the tour
season last year I've seen it in the
chessable Masters so far this year the
queen has attacked Andis needs to find a
good Square for that Queen he moves it
back onto the diagonal into the center
of the board his strategy his positional
understanding where the pieces belong it
all seems to fall into place so well and
just not on the board I was so impressed
with his answers yesterday when we when
you asked him David who's your idol
who's your hero the guy just said I've
got no Heroes he's 17 and it's just
amazing to hear him talk and to his play
is a true reflection of his personality
I think totally in order to be the best
you have to beat the best so you can't
be too differential towards them you
have to respect them but not worship
them too much you have to be ready to
pounce when the best players in the
world make mistakes and talking of the
best players in the world we see Magnus
Carson against fed that one as well
evolving there have been some big
decisions uh in that Clash the world
number one has castled queenside with
the white king the board you see on the
right of your screens there H he's also
got the bishop pair so both players with
the white pieces in these two boards
have the bishop pair longterm doing very
well but still KGI for now and fed have
trying to maneuver around with his
Knights um white Pawn structure in that
game Magnus Carson gets fed save
slightly compromised white has doubled
APS so many small factors to break down
and it's not clear who it favors yet
evaluation bar on both boards slightly
favoring white but not by much and uh it
feels like again Calm before the storm
this middle game and the clock ticking
that could be a key factor especially
the Magnus Carson game he's just gone
below the 4minute mark we mentioned
sometimes in the time scrambles even
mighty Magnus makes mistakes so um I
think we' delve deeper into that game uh
let's jump in Magnus Carson against fed
to try to evaluate has he worked this
end game magic we've been talking about
this queenless middle game will'll call
it and uh here I've got to say first
glance I like white purely because of
this Knight that he's just installed on
the C6 square but uh black has reasons
to be optimistic too Robert yeah this is
a position where it resembles the other
game in that white has the pair of
Bishops but the Queens are off the board
and of note is there doubled a pawns for
white but that's not actually a bad
thing at this stage of the game with so
many pieces remaining on the board white
can go after some of Black's targets and
black is not creating a pass Pawn
because the A2 Pawn still covers the
pawn on the B file this is maybe a deep
concept for some but the point is that
it's not like some other double pawns as
we saw in yand pomi versus Maxim Vash
earlier so this last move from M from
fedos excuse me great decision he's
trying to bring a knight to E5 or to C5
and that A4 Pawn is a target a knight in
the center usually is a good place to
put it and he wants activate his pieces
including the bishop on d8 which does
have a new diagonal to work with without
the knight in its path so Tanya as we
look at this position I think all of us
were inclined to believe that white is
better but I feel like there's some
natural plans for
black agreed and uh the point that you
just made with Bishop on d8 stepping up
to F6 taking control of the wrong long
wrong the long diagonal A1 to h8 Once
White's Bishop comes to D4 it looks like
magnus's Bishop pair Advantage is going
to be neutralized really soon either
there'll be a knight trade from C5 or
the bishop trade from F6 and the pawn
structural weaknesses in magnus's Camp
more than enough compensate for fedos
the lack of the bishop uh I love that
Knight on C6 but I'm trying to
understand why is our evalar favoring
white so much Bishop D4 there seems to
be Bishop F6 if not the Knight is
jumping forward into the game what's
going on here whoa that's going on here
that's what's going on here
w we didn't expect that and uh again the
blue arrow indicating that Black's only
move or at least by far the best move is
Rook takes Bishop that would not have
been on my radar Robert an exchange
sacrifice pretty much demanded uh by fed
right now this is a pawn sacrifice and I
just wanted to point out let's jump in
if this Pawn is captured if you just
whip this Pawn off the board what could
be more natural go up material suddenly
a new diagonal for White's uncontested
light squar bishop and tricks tactics in
the air black has two loose pieces on
this diagonal and something might well
just drop off so don't be too greedy I
think likewise if you capture at this
Pawn with the Knight there are problems
tactically Bishop takes and suddenly
watch out for your back rank you can
trade off a set of Rooks but uh now you
have to be careful if Pawn takes
suddenly a deadly check and your Bishop
will simply drop off next move so Magnus
initiating the tactics let's just show
what he okay he's played Pawn takes Pawn
he needed to play Rook takes bishop and
uh basically admit that okay if Rook
takes there are tricks in Black's favor
this time with a nice pin but Pawn takes
Pawn Robert do you think this is going
to backfire fed say have playing that
move instantly and look at magnus's
reply what you were calling for David
Bishop to B5 there are too many tactics
now and so what Magnus did is he gave
away a pawn to free up diagonals for his
Bishops and I say Bishops plural because
now that Knight on D7 if it continues to
move say to E5 well oh and he does it
move too late does fedos of the right
idea wrong move order I still feel like
he has chances to survive this game
let's not count him out just because the
evaluation bar is slightly in mag's
favor the material in Balance now is
Knight and one Pawn for rook and let's
not forget about those opposite colored
Bishops so black can use the dark
squares to his Advantage white is going
to try to operate in the light squares
but to what end what light squares are
actually valuable that's an essential
question so I like the way that fedos
state was handling this I think this
gives him the best practical
chances from it's uh just imbalanced as
we would say Tanya the players have no
idea who's better and fed I could see
him especially if he gets this pawn two
squares further down the board him
working things in his favor do you think
Magnus needs to be careful as well I'm
materialistic I love the fact that there
is an extra exchange for white and I
agree that Black's got compensation but
that Knight on C6 the bishop on B5 there
are these tactical ideas of either
Knight takes A5 or Knight takes B4 next
watch out the Knight on D7 is still
hanging it's a threat that you need to
take care of to me it just feels that FV
needs to be on the defense he needs to
keep the activity going he has to play
active to defend this position the plan
that you're pointing out of the C Pawn
moving forward the bishop on B5 right
now takes control of that so it still
requires a bit of prep right now I'm
expecting fedf to move his Knight he
does it Knight to B6 the evalar hits it
and Magnus just continues to keep
opening up the position the lines for
the Bishops and the the lines for the
Rooks and the diagonals for the Bishops
and now it's busted for black this is a
problem once this Rook gets in the game
you can see that fedos is in trouble I
think it's important to analyze what he
could have done instead and it was just
a on move play from fedos of that would
have kept him in the game rather than
opening the Rooks up Bishop to G3 just
try to blockade this D- Pawn so the
Rooks don't have open files when you're
down material especially when your
opponent has two Rooks just one for
yourself you need to keep those Rooks
contained so this would have been a good
choice instead what we see in the game
the Rooks are loose they are free to
roam about the board and now one of them
is off the board and that's bad news for
black because that A5 Pawn is tender the
defile remains open black can't keep
everything under his control and Magnus
Carlson for sure is winning this first
game
David 100% it's all about that uh Target
on A5 pretty much indefensible in the uh
kind of short term and uh this white a
por not only does it promote on a lights
Square Guided by your Bishop but it's
pretty much Unstoppable you have no
Rooks left as black yeah Knights are
terrible at stopping these Corner pawns
these Rook pawns so once the White
Knight Retreats takes this Pawn it's a
matter of time before fed has to resign
we saw him sit back exhale a moment ago
he knows it's over the white Rook
doesn't look impressive now but it will
soon join the fun and I think we'll see
very simple plan blacks C play far too
slow and uh Magnus he's going porn
hunting he's going to hunt down the full
point in in this game uh soon closing
out the victory again just in the space
of one or two moves this is how strong
the top players are they punish you one
small imperceptible slip and here we go
Knight takes porn inevitable just a
straightforward plan Magnus about to
bank it um we think Tanya should we go
to the other game where there's still
action on the
board definitely I just want to say this
is how strong Magnus Carlson can be
especially in these positions I mean we
were talking about an equal opening an
outcome where White had nothing and then
just out of nowhere Magnus comes up with
a winning position how did it happen
when did it all go so wrong it's just
unbelievable how he makes these things
just appear on the board and makes chess
look so easy it's insane he's playing
against one of the best players in the
world he has a completely winning
position out of a completely equal
opening Magnus Carlson just doing Magnus
things I think it's a good time David to
jump over to our other board Which is
far from a queenless position it's an
exciting middle game
Robert what do you make of what we're
seeing on the left side of our screen
between Dennis lazic and Jose Martinez
it's definitely heating up on the left
hand side board uh because they're open
diagonals for both players usually open
space it is good for the player with the
pair of Bishops as Jose Martinez his
cameras on the bottom left hand side of
our screen but Dennis lavic he just
doesn't back down against anyone it's
super impressive the game between Magnus
and fed is officially over no surprises
there Magnus takes game one so now we
can fully be attentive to this game on
the left hand side of our screen between
Jose and Dennis Magnus up one to nothing
one of these players would like to join
him I mean David look at Jose's clock
he's down under that minute but we know
he's a bullet brawler he's won a number
of
them we we're used to seeing this from
Jose at this point yesterday against Yan
pomi every time we jumped into that game
he had like five 10 seconds on his clock
yet he was able to maneuver he
checkmated yand pomi twice and wow is
this a blunder from Dennis lavic why is
this a mistake Queen to F6 he's trying
to trade off the Queens but Rook takes
D5 just wins a piece there's actually
wow some brilliant tactics here some
back rank
ideas I wonder whether he'll see it if
not we will show it a double question
mark a blunder but an understandable one
from Dennis lazic and J Pam Jose
Martinez spots it Queen sacrifice
exclamation mark and he's going to show
the reason look at this Rook takes D4 at
the end a pin and you win you're going
to emerge with a rook and two Bishops
for a queen mathematically this one is
pretty much over brilliant Robert just
in the blink of an eye and you could see
Jose he was quizzically looking at wait
this doesn't look right I didn't spot
Queen F6 on my radar and Dennis shakes
his head like I should have seen that
come on and the point is that lose
pieces drop off a rook and two Bishops
they overwhelm a queen it's worth more
in value Bishops two Bishops and a rook
that's worth 11 maybe even 12 to a
queen's nine so this one it should be
easy conversion now Tanya I mean Dennis
Laz he doesn't blunder often but he just
had a critical error at that moment and
now it seems game one for josam Rob
we've been talking about how Dennis
makes no mistakes it we haven't seen
that happen and this was a big tactical
blunder and this puts him on the back
foot I think it's a hard one to recover
from the bishop can line up now
threatening Bishop to E4 a huge pinch
you have to watch out for there will be
coordination between the rook and the
two Bishops one of the Rooks will come
on to the open file either the B line or
the a line and for Dennis lavic it is a
desperate situation too much material
down you have to be a little careful
white needs to fall back with the bishop
the D3 Pawn can be picked up at the
moment because the Rook on E2 is tied
down to defend the bishop on D2 yes that
pawn may drop but David I feel like this
is for someone of Jose's caliber just so
easy this is a walk for him because
you're going have to push your pawns
that opens up more diagonals and the
white king is too
safe simply black has fewer pieces
you've got a queen great but Rooks and
Bishops do a great job at containing a
queen and you have two of those Bishops
so yeah it feels like a matter of time
Jose he's done the hard work but then
again there are tricks uh I was gonna
say is there a trick he was wow double
attack suddenly from Dennis
lazic yeah he thought Queen D1 check he
missed Queen B5 Tanya what a f from
Dennis and Jose can't believe it and it
was because he was down to 5 seconds on
the clock he's in big danger now and
maybe white is still fine because you've
got that extra pawn and you can set up a
fortress but this is heartbreaking Jose
needs to get himself together and make
sure that there are no more misses right
now he's down to seconds on the clock I
think he's still going to win the game
David I don't know about you but I'd
much rather have all of these pieces for
the queen there's no attack against the
white king but Jose he's still shaking
his head David I don't think he's over
it understandably he's going to be
kicking himself he had an easily winning
position we were just praising him uh
talking about how it should be pretty
much automatic and it would have been if
he hadn't walked into a double attack so
moral of the story everyone keep your
pieces defended protect each other
coordinate loose pieces drop off and he
put his Bishop on A5 far away from the
rest of his army no surprise that the
tactics didn't work in his favor but
okay he's going for the black king now
Bishop H5 a monster threat Dennis has to
work out with no time on his clock can
he simply take this Pawn I think he can
but then he might have to run with the
black king forward so uh still scary
times here Jose recovering but setting
the traps Bishop H five still on top
Dennis this is not over he still has to
find really accurate moves to save
this David that's a really nice move
taking away that F6 squ Bishop H5 Rook
to E8 was a big threat check's coming in
I I think this is going to end in a draw
now that the queen and the king of are
separated you're not going to lose the
queen but without white having connected
pawns it's hard to imagine a passer for
Jose either dra the most likely uh oh
what a find he gives away his Pawn to
save his King and now ad draw I would
say is more likely batan until that move
was found I thought that Dennis was in
some
trouble wow and Jose continues to shake
his head he can't believe what he's just
missed he was rook and two Bishops for a
queen blundering in one move but this is
this is rapid and he shakes his head he
knows this is over this is ending in a
draw any moment now David miracles do
happen Dennis lazic that's why you never
ever give up he blundered he was pretty
much just a piece down for nothing but
he kept fighting and even there they
were checkmating attacks against his
King but he's a coldblooded Defender so
impressive stuff um yeah just tactical
vision for both of these two players
really at the top of their game you can
tell two slips one on either side
ultimately balancing each other out and
now we will see a repetition
and draw is confirmed Battle of the
underdogs in the end after a few twist
and turns after a roller coaster ended
peacefully wow breathless action Tanya
that was an up and down game what a game
that was a big blunder by Dennis first
and then Jose Martinez Returns the
favors with just seconds on the clock
and you can see the one player who is
disappointed with this result for Jos
bam it has been a disappointing draw
Robert he was so close oh he was so
close to securing game one against
Dennis lazic but Dennis he has a lot of
fighting him he may just be 17 but he's
used to brawling here on the internet in
the chess scene and you see that Dennis
he he's has reason to smile he now is
tied half half after a single game
meanwhile Magnus Carlson he won his
first game so I don't think Vladimir FV
is feeling happy in the
slightest for FV he needs to make a
comeback in his match he needs to score
a win to level the score Magnus doing
Magnus things in that one out of nowhere
out of a quick Queen trade he just makes
one of the most difficult games known to
mankind chest makes makes it look also
easy just converts it in a couple of
moves I don't know how the guy does it
David what is the
secret I know maybe it's something in
the water in Norway either way he works
miracles and we saw the mess the madness
uh the kind of loss of control in that
last game between Martinez and lazovic
Magnus having none of it just seamless
asking questions of his opponent and
unfortunately for fed who we see on the
camera right now he didn't quite have
the answers uh he looks very
philosophical I've got to say staring
out to the distance just wondering where
it all went wrong maybe he's just coming
up with a new strategy but that is what
we were talking about you cannot let
Magnus assume control assume dominance
in one of those slower strategic type of
positions he out Maneuvers the best of
us you need to take your chances ask
really difficult questions make the
position irrational and just hope that
it pays off unfortunately that's the
best chance against one of the best
players of uh dress and I think we're
getting ready to go any moment now
Magnus doesn't look too happy but he
played great in that first
one Robert I'm still thinking about what
we spoke earlier for fed sa he needs to
find a way to get those positions where
two plus two is indeed equal to five to
find his
chances that Forest though is hard to
find and navigate against Magnus Carlson
because he's the number one player in
the world he's been that for over a
decade so if anyone has the compass even
when it seems like they're blindfolded
and on their own it's Magnus so I feel
like for fedosov he showed yesterday
that he can storm back from a deficit
but what he did against Ali Raza fuia is
he went all out he he put his Queen off
the side of the board stole a pawn was
greedy I'm not sure it's going to work
two days in a row so feda he starts with
a pretty quiet opening we'll see if he's
willing to throw his pawns forward just
like we saw for example Anish giri do at
the end of Tata steel sometimes you have
to throw all your pieces forward
everything but the kitchen sink and go
for the attack
David yeah I fully agree and uh he would
love to do that I've seen fet have do
that plenty of times with a lot of
success but against different type of
opposition of course is easy to say
against someone that he would out rate
throw your pawns forward attack go for
it and it's another whole mindset to do
it against Magnus so uh right now it's a
Queen's Gambit declined it's the cbad
pawn structure we've been talking about
with pawns on E3 D4 against pawns on C6
D5 but Magnus loves these types of Pawn
structures now he's aiming to trade off
these Bishops and the fewer pieces on
the board the better Magnus becomes
remember so I love this decision I was
about to say keep those bits on keep
those Bishops just in case you need them
for a later attack Magnus doesn't look
too happy what do you make of the body
language and the start of this game
Tanya
the way he won the first game I think
he's got all the reasons to be happy
right now it's hard to say how he's
feeling but I think he's very pleased
with the quality of player from that
game one he jumps in with the Knight to
the center of the board uh and for white
I was just about to say needs to take a
decision fedf does he put the Knight on
F3 or the other plan that we see with
the Knight moving in front of the king
to E2 instead fed CH choses the approach
where eventually the Knight can jump
further on the Knight can land on to E5
we might even see him try to build
Chances with shock cast the F Pawn
moving forward F4 F5 in certain
positions but having white he needs to
make sure that he does create as much of
a possibility to get a game out of this
one as much as he can because it only
gets harder harder on from here well
with the white pieces he has two whites
in these final three games does fedos
say have as you're saying T he needs to
make the most of it and I like his
position optically it's pleasing you
have all four of your minor pieces out
on the third rank you control key
squares and namely the F5 squares like
black can't easily jump forward in this
position and so the next moves aren't
obvious for how black should develop
your Bishop on C8 tucked at home you may
want to go all the way out to G4 but
that walks into Tanya's plan with Knight
to E5 so David as we look at this
position you know Magnus very well he
might have to settle for a cramped
structure do you think that he's quite a
displeased with what he's achieved out
of the opening I think Magnus is happy
with the pawn structure he's got he's
happy with the skeleton of the position
but uh as you say Robert there's no
natural plans and Magnus he's probably
better than anyone at just putting his
pieces on good squares finding nice
homes for them here It's Tricky even for
the likes of Magnus and like you say
awward squares so he's in two minds he's
happy that he's got a solid foundation
but awkward squares for his pieces like
this E6 Point uh we never like to see
Bishops uh kind of staring at their own
pawns they look like big Pawns in this
type of position and yeah it's just
about how Magnus is able to maneuver
Maybe after pushing the a pawn he'll
bring his Knight out via A6 maybe he'll
bring the Knight back round to sit by
his King he's Rock Solid and he's a
point up in the match so he has
something to play with it's just about
whether fev can attack and uh on the
flip side I don't really see exactly
what white should be doing often here we
talk about minority attacks throwing two
pawns forward to uh undermine these
three on the queen side but that is less
attractive with the Black Knight sitting
in the center nicely poised to jump into
any holes uh later on and we F he's
maneuvering this is exciting this is
instructive as well going towards this
black king he's just edging towards the
king side he's going to try and put some
pressure on this black Bishop first of
all but watch out for some nasty checks
just in case if you keep uh kind of if
you forget to keep your king uh safe
later so yeah I could go on about these
Pawn structures forever I'll stop now
but uh I think that Magnus isn't as
comfortable as he would like to be
T I agree with you and I think for
Magnus it's also going to be be key to
try and get a central break of C5 in at
the right moment because if fight is
given a free hand we can see that attack
Brewing up on the king side Knight F4
Knight E5 you might eventually jump with
the Knight to H5 the F F Pawn moving
forward so for Magnus once he's already
lined up the queen with the bishop also
hinting at C5 Knight can come to D7 or
A6 and defend that I was expecting fedf
to land on the E5 square with his Knight
but we see a different plan here Bishop
to E5 Robert does the surprise you it
does and I think that Magnus suddenly
has fixed all of his problems because
his latest move bring his Queen to C8
may look unusual but he's lining his
Queen and Bishop up so Bishop to F5
trade pieces when you have less space
and in this position black is feeling a
bit cramped you haven't fully developed
SO trading pieces should be favorable
for Magnus Carlson and as soon as I say
it he plays it I think that he has
neutralized the opening Advantage from
the white side but the game continues
because there isn't complete clarity as
David pointed out White's Knights are
heading towards the black king it can be
a bit scary if you are not accurate but
now that the development is complete I
do think Magnus he has everything under
control and it's a timely uh sip of
water or whatever is in that bottle
there because he's feeling good about
his position
T yeah I think David you were asking
about magnus's body language I think
this has got to be a lot more relaxed
for him now now that one set of minor
pieces are off the board he's managed to
get rid of what what is considered one
of the big problems pieces in these kind
of Pawn structure the light Squad Bishop
you really want to trade that off and
he's done it which solves a lot of
problems but still white feels like
setting up for that Minority attack you
had mentioned earlier The Rook now lined
up with the queen B4 A4 B5 in the air uh
how does black continue to improve and
fight these ideas
David well uh Magnus knows better than
me but he has a few options uh I just
wanted to say completely on your point
Tanya the pawns control light squares
now the bishop will control dark squares
later it's a great strategy uh and also
a note for everyone at home if you're
cramped if you're struggling for space
if your pieces are suffocating just
trade off one set of minor pieces
Knights and Bishops and you live uh you
kind of breathe easier and uh yeah I was
going to say actually on the last move
Magnus could have gone for a double
attack I was slightly surprised the
Black Knight didn't jump in to hit this
Pawn first of all uh which has just
moved it was sitting on B2 but also the
black knight from C4 would have hit this
bishop in the center um so Magnus he
could have actually forced the issue
traded more pieces off and felt probably
safer but now what he would love to do
is somehow get either the Queens off or
maybe one set of knights off he'd love
to trade off white Bishop sitting pretty
in the center um ultimately though there
we go I was going to say just before
that magnus's trademark move is to push
Rooks pawns flank pawns um reinvigorated
by Alpha zero in 2019 Magnus had one of
his best years and he loves kind of
gaining space on the flanks watch out
now for this backward Pawn to be an
issue later the black Rook could slide
so Magnus has got a bunch of ideas in
the meantime I don't really see what fed
should be doing right now uh ultimately
this Pawn structure is something Magnus
is known for and fed I thought his
opening was a success but one or two
moves later the departure of those
Bishops and suddenly it's just a
position as we say it's just roughly
level and uh I do fear f his chances um
so okay this is one to check in on a bit
later um maybe let's zoom out and go to
the bird's ey view to check in on the
other game The Clash of The Underdogs
after those Mutual blunders a bit
earlier who will recover best and uh
Robert we see it on the left s left hand
side there first glance who do you favor
oh we got that Bon structure on the left
hand side of our screen and Jose
Martinez just hops in with his Knight I
have to say that his position looks very
solid from the black side Dennis lazic
you know not like he's done anything
wrong himself he's pushing pawns into
Center but I think that there are
chances for black to strike and that is
the standard for this opening so as we
Dive In in to the X's and O's I just
also want to note that the clock the
situation seems perfectly acceptable for
both players but I'm looking at strikes
over on the Queens side for black with a
move like Pawn to B5 that's one of
Jose's main ideas and for Dennis he's
expanded his Center can he push F4 next
to boot that Queen out of there Tanya
these are not easy decisions but you're
a D4 player so you must have experience
in the
structure you're right Robert and in
these positions it's so important for
white to keep as many minor pieces as
possible because white does have the
space Advantage you were talking about
the break on the queen side a very
thematic B5 idea but Jose Martinez goes
for another thematic idea which is to
try to get play on the king side he
pushes the G Pawn forward you have to
watch out for this G Pawn from G5 going
one step ahead to G4 really cramping
down on the king side gaining more space
isolating that E4 Pawn making sure that
the F Pawn remains a backward Pawn on F2
I really like this aggressive play by
Jose and it really puts Dennis into the
think right now two minor two sets of
minor pieces off the board in these
structures it does favor Black uh
David Y and uh exactly this bononi is
all about trading once at a pieces so
you're not struggling for space as we
mentioned in the other game and uh
talking of fighting for space he's been
stopped on the king side he's now
throwing pawns forward on the queen side
I was going to say Black's uh pawn move
Pawn to G5 it's The Sweet Spot it's
active and it's strategic uh is kind of
playing dynamically but also stopping
White's main plan of pushing a pawn to
F4 for good but now it's all about the
other side of the board and uh how does
Dennis react there a bit of a positional
threat to capture on C5 due to the fact
that blacks uh pinned on the B file this
Rook undefended on the back rank ideally
you would love to move this bishop out
the way therefore always connect your
Rooks if you can but White's Queen also
peering down at this Pawn a bit awkward
I've got to say I think Dennis has
chosen the right moment of strike so um
I love what uh joose bam I keep saying
joose bam instead of Jose but what he's
been doing so far but still questions to
answer and he trades off and this is a
high responsibility decision because now
he's left with a backward Pawn forever
and he has to back this up with active
PE idea I guess Robert is to activate
his pieces to uh better outposts taking
control of some key dark squares why not
and I think a critical point is that
this A5 move it challenges the white
rook and says where are you going so
look at Dennis he backs it up and so
quickly does Jose play Knight to D7 look
at how he's played G5 to stop White's F4
Pawn push then playing on the queen side
so Jose understands the structure he
understands where his pieces belong and
White's pieces look pretty optimally
placed but that's not good enough you
need to come up with plans rather than
just say hey this is a good aesthetic I
I'm feeling nice what is the next plan
for white I'm still looking at a way to
try and push the pawn to F4 but it does
open up both Kings it's not going to be
a one-sided attack both players need to
watch out at this stage
Tanya you're absolutely right about that
and I think there are two plans in these
positions uh Robert for white you either
try to push F4 which is a double-edge
sword because you open the G line for
both you could do that with either
shifting your Rook from D1 to F1 to
support the advance or perhaps the queen
could fall back to D2 or E3 the main
idea is to defend this F4 Square try and
push black Queen's back uh Queen back
and then expand in the center the other
idea that I see for white is maybe
another shift the more strategic plan to
try to double up on the dline making
sure that Black's Knight on D7 stays as
a defensive piece I see that Dennis has
gone for Queen to E3 he wants to get F4
in and he does it this is blowing up
this is opening up and it's not a
one-sided attack as you pointed out
because the G file opens for both
players we're perhaps going to see a
trade on F4 and then the queen fall
falls back the king will shift to h8
and who lands on the G line
first yeah it's just a race now it's
going to be mutual attacks I was looking
at the queen side for the last few moves
Tanya and then uh suddenly attention
switches Elsewhere for both players and
um I just want to talk as well as this
one really starts to heat up about uh
that previous game surely if you're Jose
Martinez you get frustrated Dennis lazic
just never loses and uh now he's the one
on the attack he's the one pushing do
you think Jose's happy with the outcome
here um especially as his position is
kind of hanging by threat E5 now in the
air it's uh it's lurking what's going
through is mind
r that he's probably a bit scared E5 is
a tremendous threat it hits the queen on
F6 but it also tries to Spring free some
pass Pawns in the center and Black's
pieces are pretty well placed the Rook
on B8 it protects a pawn in front of it
the Rook on E8 it tries to counter
White's ideas in the center the queen on
F6 the Knight on C5 they're very clearly
uh on active squares so now it was The
Bishop's turn so he plays Bishop D7 he
kind of had to not that it was the only
good move but t as I look at this white
is playing E5 whether you like it or not
so at least create a counter threat and
that pawn on A4 that one is in the line
of fire from Black's pieces
now this is really heating up E5 on the
board black is going for the queen side
with the pawn weaknesses White NOW steps
away with the King it looks like it's
going to be White's Rook that's going to
be arriving first on the G line black
has to take a moment out I don't believe
you can capture on A4 right now Rook G1
just looks far too menacing Denis the
Menace you give him Rook G1 and that's
going to be trouble it might be time for
Jose to step aside with his own King to
h8 to try to dodge all these ideas along
the G
file say King h8 Tanya and I agree it
might well be the best move but I don't
say it with confidence because it's also
sitting on an open diagonal potentially
and uh I wonder whether in the near
future he's going to try and drop his
Queen on the D3 Square just at any cost
it might come at the cost of a pawn and
uh it's just more important to survive
with your king get those Queens off at
any cost um that would be the other main
move on my radar at least right now for
Martinez three minutes on the clock if
you're getting attacked you have to
maintain some time and uh there we go
Queen to D3 I think a good practical
decision uh evaluation Bar says no of
course but at least now with Queens off
he will live to fight another day and uh
as we saw in the previous game when the
clock taks down he's really strong in
that L latter phase um so I decision to
survive from it but I think I understand
why this gets a question mark just like
Jose exploited a game ago I think the
fact that the queen is loose on D3
allows white to play Knight to E4 now
and you can't touch that Knight on e4 oh
he he missed it but Knight E4 was
Untouchable that Knight would have
landed on F6 with a check against the
king the rook and the bishop all at once
so uh that Skirmish that those tactical
sequences there were favorable for
Dennis but we know it's in his style to
play the positional choice if he can so
I I think that his position isn't bad in
the live board underneath me here but
this would have been aggressive and
playing for a bit more H it comes with
risk that's for sure loose pawns
everywhere but it also would have been
playing with strength with the
initiative so I think Tanya at this
stage we just saw the Queens come off
the board a mistake was made but it was
Overlook so really was it a mistake at
all uh to me the big question is can't
black just now pick up the A4 Pawn I see
that the D6 Pawn might be hanging after
you give a check on G3 but at the end of
it once you give a check white black
side steps The Rook on D1 is hanging as
well so you can't immediately capture D6
you probably have to trade the bishop
for the Knight first it just feels like
the a pawn can be really dangerous here
for Jose Martinez it might be the moment
to start looking for chances because
even if white immediately imately not
immediately eventually captures on D6
that white Pawn on D6 David will be a
weakness maybe we can just show it
Knight takes Bishop Knight takes Knight
Rook to G3 check King moves this time I
think f8 would be the square of choice
and then you gra on D6 first the D6 is a
weak Pawn but also look at that A5 Pawn
it's a protected pass Pawn a good good
Knight on A4 this end game could be very
dangerous for white David definitely
White's Bishop is not playing a role and
uh I think the most important Point as
you called it Tanya this is not a real
uh strength uh maybe the stronger point
is the one behind it tying down a black
Rook once it takes the four uh runner
the front D Pawn but yeah essentially
it's all about Black's Queens side
majority and I actually think black has
a pretty clear path to victory in this
game white with no counterplay at all so
difficult difficult decision here for
Dennis lazic let's go back I don't think
he should get greedy instead he plays
the move Rook to G1 and uh he's going
for the black king somehow but uh but
how wow Pawn to E6 trying to deflect
away this Black Knight the Black Knight
is forced to defend its Bishop so you
cannot take too many times on this E6
square and now he's aiming just for a
pawn storm Pawn to E6 followed by Pawn
to F5 F forward here and um at least
he's mixing it up I think a really
clever decision there from Dennis Robert
I watched Jose shake his head he
overlooked this move E6 I'm shaking my
head too because it's a pawn race this E
Pawn accompanied by an F Pawn that looks
scary but as T mentioned there's an A
and A B Pawn for black and those pawns
can Rumble forward too so I'm worried
about the black king I'm worried about
all of these past PA and I'm also
worried about Jose's clock Tanya we keep
talking about how he's doing well on you
know even in time scrambles this is very
tactical so you are GNA have to be extra
careful here to survive this position
against Dennis
laic couldn't degree more with that
we've seen Jose just how accurate he is
with little time on the clock even if
the positions really complicated and
although White's the one who's down upon
and yes we pointed out that a passer but
this last move by Dennis that's
terrifying White's got a protected past
Pawn on E6 now and our computer is
showing the best move the Knight
rerouting itself to D4 wire E2 attacking
that F5 weakness I'm picking white right
now despite Jose being the one who Pawn
up I think black's got to be the one
who's who has to be careful in this
position but David he Cho is another
plan he wants to put this bishop on
H5 love it The Bishop's coming in um it
might just come in anyway Bishop to H5
plunk it down on F7 and there's going to
be all sorts of checkmating ideas around
the black king um the allseeing
overlords the Silicon overlords there
the computers say Knight to E2 first
even stronger and uh again same plan
Knight back and once it lands on E2
comes forward into D4 beautiful Outpost
and this is the big weakness in Black's
position the F5 Pawn I think Jose needed
to bite the bullet and uh just trade off
pawns earlier because this one yes he's
blocked up white for a move or two but
it's going to fall in the long term
instead Dennis puts his Bishop on H5
very natural move and again the blue
arrow indicates Black's best move by far
you need to trade off one set of Rooks
but I'm going to say that's not obvious
um it's not instinctive you normally
would want to keep a rook behind pass
pawns throw this Pawn down the board
it's simply to stop White's checkmating
ideas if you allow this bishop to land
on F7 and the white Rook to slide over
to G3 then black will be doomed so you
need to trade before it's too late Rook
to G8 only way to save this game he's
got 30 seconds left
though H I don't envy his chances Robert
no and you can see it on his face and
look he was Bishop E8 the evaluation it
goes all the way up and I think it's
because white can bring the knight in
and there Dennis goes Knight D4 hitting
F5 going to C6 with checkm threats the
loose Pawns in Black's position I just
feel like they're going to drop off a
rook goes to G5 as well if you want to
win F5 directly this looks painful as
the wh's pawns feel faster than black
Tanya David I'm looking at this and I'm
thinking Dennis he's got this under
control the race and you're ahead you've
got a head start porn on E6
Tanya and Robert this is something You'
always said it's not about the quantity
of Pawns it's about the quality of Pawns
and that pawn on E6 is is worth more
than just the one Pawn a deficit that
white has right now look at the peace
activity Dennis also up on the clock
Jose shaking his head he's down to 37
seconds the F5 Pawn is falling the
Knight is coming in the a pawn hasn't
really gone down the board that move
E6 Robert I think that was the moment
that it changed the game it changed the
Dynamics and it took Jose by big
surprise the keyw is dynamic it changed
the game from one where both players
were little pushing pawns trying to gain
the upper hand and then made it Dynamic
and look at this position as David draws
the arrows David you take it away this
is such a nice find from Dennis to
secure Victory it seems he's calculated
so deeply he's going to throw his Knight
out the way with a check now a fork
clearing the path for the coronation of
his ewn he's going to make a queen this
is game over beautiful there from Dennis
lazovic he spotted it all a mile away
this is just wonderful play Queen coming
Jose Martinez is going to resign and
there we go Dennis gets the win
beautiful play we're all so impressed
right now just incredible Precision by
Dennis lazovic starting from that move
E6 amazing conversion and spectacular
end with that move Knight G6 Au cannot
stop the pawn from queening and Dennis
lavic takes the first win of this match
which means that for Jose he needs to
win a game to level the score and
meanwhile FV is about to bounce back in
his match against Magnus Robert oh a
long time ago in a position far away it
looked like Magnus had everything under
control but look at the evaluation bar
but also the last couple moves it is two
extra pawns for
fed say of but maybe Magnus could use
one of his pawns as a distraction and
try to grab a couple of his own a
reminder to all of our newer audience
members out there if white just has a
knight and a king against an enemy King
there is no way to check me so that's
what black is aiming for get rid of all
of White's pawns even if it cost you a
night and that's what fed will avoid so
David do you see any chances you know
how to grind like a grandmas can Magnus
try anything he can and he is trying
everything possible uh to draw this game
to give up the Black Knight give up the
black pawns for all of White's remaining
foot soldiers there but computer is
indicating actually only one winning
move F doesn't find it he had to give a
KN check first and actually maybe needed
to keep more pawns alive because
suddenly Magnus as you said is going to
use the gon as a distraction and then
the black king is just going to eat up
White's remaining pawns the black king
is going to come in and uh some easy
targets now that's uh oh I've jinxed him
commentator's curse why is that a
mistake and has got away with it he's
going to come in now fed have actually
could have given a check we'll show this
later that was a beautiful idea to
maintain a winning position Robert and
you only see that because the evaluation
bar is off to the side nobody is looking
for it David will show it after the game
but now we see the result should not be
in too much doubt you go after the white
pawns and that was another great move by
the way King B5 that eliminates any
questions instead of trying to bring
your king away from that pass Pawn I
think you guys spotted it maybe with the
Val bar but I think Magnus spotted it we
saw him react right now I think he knows
that there was that moment that fedos
have missed the win and now it's
everything under control for Magnus he
survives it he doesn't only have the
incredible ability to win winning
positions but he also has the ability to
survive lost positions and Magnus
Carlson does it again saves the game and
it ends in a draw but there was a moment
David when FV could have won that end
game yes he could indeed have won that
end game Magnus Houdini Carson though
gets away with it yet again and I just
wanted to very briefly show if we have
the opportunity fed have pondering uh
looking uh at his missed opportunities
but first this is the breakdown Tanya
these are the scores on the doors and
Dan as lasic with a spectacular win with
the white pieces takes the lead in his
match meanwhile Magnus cson survives a
big scare in that night and pawn end
game fed have almost bounced back but
almost is not good enough against the
world number one
David no not enough so close though
Robert so so close but against the top
players you have to put the chances in
the back of the net and here I just
wanted to point out Knight to E5 check
was the winning move and uh in order to
Simply deflect away the black king but
this is another story let's show the
more spectacular of the two wins after a
trade of Pawns he brought his King
forward and Magnus actually slipped up
here he brought uh his Pawn forward and
then went straight in with King to D5 he
needed to first throw away the pawn
Force the black king the white king
sorry even further away and then go with
the Knight to start taking the white
pawns with a draw miraculously three
pawns down instead however after King
dd5 the miracle win Knight E3 check as
pointed out by the computer and after
King takes Pawn you throw the Knight
away as well deflect this Black Knight
and look how far away the Black Knight
is from this Pawn Knights are the worst
at stopping Corner pawns these flank
pawns and white would have made a new on
the game One Missed opportunity there
for fed and Magnus gets away with
it so close yet so far for V FV he still
needs to needs a win to bounce back in
this match and it's also the same
storyline for Jose Martinez who had a
heartbreaking loss in the last one so
much in control but Dennis lazic scoring
a big win we've got a big game three
action coming right up don't go anywhere
as the players we'll be
[Music]
back
welcome to a world where each game
writes a new story with endless
possibilities and surprising twists we
present the next big new tournament the
freestyle chess goat challenge at the
Forefront of this epic chess spectacle
is none other than Magnus Carlson the
former world champion facing his first
duel with the reigning world champion
ding Len since his title victory in
addition to this top duel Carlson has
selected six other top Challengers to
make the tournament especially exciting
be sure to watch all the games on the
live stream at chess.com and on our
freestyle-house-music-genre
our once magnificent Kingdom of Chess
lays now in ruins our King slain but
some say that a new ruler will come and
restore the realm to its former glory
solve puzzles fight epic battles and
earn gold swords and Scrolls full of
Chess wisdom on your way to reclaiming
the throne download the app today and
this month only face off against your
favorite Kingdom character Bots only on
chess.com
[Music]
3 2
4 he
[Music]
go
it's always a pleasure to be joined by
one of my favorite people on the planet
none other than Grandmaster marce Ashley
Maurice how you doing my friend yo
Robert what's good what's good you know
I'm so happy to talk to you we haven't
chatted about the Nicks of late so happy
to be on the show we could talk about
that for hours though so let's get back
to the
action well Maurice the Knicks are up to
big things but I hear that you're up to
big things as well so what do you got
for us what what do you have to announce
for
everybody well we had a special contest
that we announced back in uh November SL
December seemed so long ago now uh it is
the create your own course contest and
chessable of course loves to get
everybody the entire Community involved
and they had 73 submissions in three
different languages we had six English
language finalists and I was naturally
going to be presenting the winner I'm
going to be giving the voice over for
the winner but it turns out we had
something really special only this time
happen happening in fact we have two
winners and that's the Shocker two
courses were such high quality that we
could not distinguish it we said you
know what give it to them both show them
both love this is just for the work that
they've put in and so we're excited to
be able to do that and and uh announce
the two winners make them very happy
well sounds like extra work for you as
well how has it been working with the
ches team how's this experience been for
you it's been extraordinary going to
Barcelona on a regular basis how am I
supposed to complain about that I am
going as well next week so Barcelona has
been like my new city I might as well
move like you to Europe or get on that
side of the pond because I'm always over
there but the chessable team is just
fantastic uh all the people who helped
me so much to make just super
comfortable so I love working with chess
and the courses that I've already
created and looking into creates many
many more well I love to hear that so
without further Ado why don't you tell
tell me who are the winners and what are
the courses you'll be
making indeed let's get right to it the
first winner is Advanced chess patterns
by Benedictine and we all know that
patterns are important in chess all of
us know our standard patterns and he did
make a course Before Common chess
patterns but he has upped his game now
and brought the patterns that gms's like
a Robert has would spot in a millisecond
I saw you spot that Knight E4 in that
game followed by Knight F6 that inzo
that lazaric should have seen those kind
of things are what are going to be in
that course and then the other one the
killer Kings by Icebreaker and this is
about the Kings doing big things the
king marching down the board like a
Nigel short walk or a petan King march
to the left when it's like what is that
about but you know you're nodding your
head like yeah yeah I know that one but
yes we going to show that to the fans as
well also castling to win you know those
are always exciting when you Castle
queenside pick off a rook on B2 maybe
Castle kingside all those are examples
of how the king can be used as a
fighting piece and those courses were so
welld designed well thought through that
we just thought it was necessary to make
both of them winners well I love that
those both sound like excellent courses
and Maurice in your Hall of Fame speech
you said that you the game of chess's
biggest fan so what what advice would
you give to fans of the game who may
want to create their own course me how
do you see that
process you know nowadays it's so much
easier back in the day it was all about
books but now that we have so much
digital material if you have an idea
that you are a fan of something that
really tickles your fancy for me it was
chess geometry my very first chess book
course the secrets of Chess geometry
which has been a runaway success the the
idea of geometry in chess it's so
beautiful when you see all kinds of
these geometric Maneuvers zigzags
dominations and the like so when you
have an idea nowadays you can take a
database and filter that database to
show you comb through that database to
show you the way your idea can be
presented in pure form there are
millions of games and in those millions
of games they going to be a 100 200
examples of whatever idea you consider
to be one of your favorites and that's
what I would recommend come up with an
idea just learn how to filter it through
a through databases like chess base and
once you do that you're on your way wow
I mean you couldn't have said it any
better so it sounds like Maurice you
recommend that teachers and those who
want improve they maybe get and enjoy
the waiting list for the courses that
you're about to
make yeah I would say so there are a lot
of quality chessable courses they keep
cring them out it looks like many times
a month but there definitely going to be
topics that you're intrigued by for me
it's less like the openings I don't say
Chessa is great at studying openings
nowadays remember how painful it was for
us Robert back in the day trying to comb
through opening lines nowadays it's just
spoonfed to you so that is definitely
there but I have to say I have a special
preference for those middle games and
especially those end games where you see
these weird things happening that idea
that was missed by fed of that night C2
check followed by A6 and the Knight
can't get back it's not just that it was
a Side Pawn it's just the exact setup of
this Knight on the second Rank and a
Pawn on the sixth the Knight just can't
get back to catch it those kind of
geometric concepts are just beautiful
and those are my favorites whenever
somebody does something like that on
chess well those are your favorites as I
said you're one of my favorite people on
the planet your energy is contagious and
you may be one of the chess's biggest
fans but I'm one of your biggest fans
ever since I was a kid we catch up we'll
catch up soon of course man but continue
doing what you're doing we love to see
all the content you're bringing there
and well continue being a fan and
watching the champion chest St I'm a fan
of what you all are doing absolutely you
David and Tanya you are killing it you
know I've retired from chess commentary
on a regular basis but I there's no loss
because you all are keeping it at an
extremely high level so keep up the good
work well thank you my friend thank you
for passing the torch and we are heading
back to the Champions chess tour you
heard Grandmaster Maurice Ashley he is
creating his two courses but a course
can be written just about these matches
here in the champ Champion chestor the
chessable Masters is our first Lego
season David and Tanya you're back and
we'll be back with a one and a half lead
for both Magnus Carlson and Dennis lck
and the games they're getting
underway Rober the games are underway
we've seen our story storyline Magnus
Carlson survived in that last game these
endgame geometry that Maurice was
pointing at so beautiful such a big Miss
by fedf he starts with the black pieces
if Magnus gets the dub in this one if he
wins with white it's match over for fedf
so he needs to make sure things stay
under control and speaking of things
staying under control I think this is an
opening that needs to be broken down
David Knight takes E4 offering white to
pick up that night it looks like it's
for free it looks like it's for free
this is H the fourn night Scotch as we
call it one of the most drawish openings
if you believe top ground Masters but
not this move fed save throwing a knight
away I'm just going to show a quick
Action Replay uh before it's too late
there we go of Black's last move let's
go back a couple of turns it was here
after Knight takes D4 Knight takes E4 a
big shock the main move in that position
being uh for example Bishop out to B4
but uh instead Knight takes E4 on the
board and uh Magnus wow he goes for a
variation uh that's forcing the Queens
off again just slow Action Replay here
Knight takes Knight would have been met
by a couple of different moves but Queen
to E7 is one of them you pin and you do
win back the material due to this line
and the White Queen being tied down to
the White Knight in the center let's
catch up with the game however uh just a
temporary night sacrifice but Magnus uh
instead uh playing a different variation
trading everything off and uh let's just
bring that game back for you and Wow
Let's see he's pieace down if I'm to
trust the live board right now I'm going
to try and fix uh what we've got in
front of us but um level material
robertt uh looks at least to my eyes
like Magnus has been caught off guard in
these early stages well as we catch up
with the live position the Queens are
off and that doesn't mean that the game
just concludes so uh we see underneath
me here that the uh King for black is
out in the open the king for white is
uncast and will not legally be able to
Castle uh but while I have a quick
second I I do want to shout out Maurice
more time and I said that I was one of
Maurice's biggest fans it's true
can't believe I'm saying this publicly
but Tanya I know you'll appreciate this
when I was a kid Maurice was at a
tournament playing doing analysis all
that stuff and I was too nervous to go
up to him and ask for his autograph I
was like nine years old and my mom she's
ever the Bold character she just storms
right over to where Maurice is like my
son he's a big fan of yours can he get a
an autograph I don't know if we have a
photo I'll have to ask my parents but
ever since I was a kid I've had so much
respect for mace I'm honored to call him
a friend and now that we have said that
I'm happy to go back into the chess
where there's a check against the black
king out in the
open the deadly well I was going to say
deadly it's not that deadly the black
king C Retreat I'm just so used to all
those King marches Maurice name dropped
some of those great king walks of all
time and I don't think we'll see the
black king continue its Journey Down the
board out into the open uh it's well
hopefully learned a lesson from Max Vash
gra King we'll see the black king surely
just Retreat and drop back there we go
to safety and now the game will take a
slower turn blacks Bishops can come out
to very nice sensible squares I think
roughly level position the fireworks in
this game happened right off the bat
really really early and uh yeah just uh
before we move on from Maurice I just
want to shout out to him as well I
remember one of my first chess memories
watching his commentary 1994 those Intel
rapid tournaments where he was
commentating with Danny King and that
got me into this beautiful game so a big
shout out to one of our chess Heroes and
in the meantime Dan uh Dan Tanya
even David I'm gonna join both of you in
that I um I'm also a big Maurice Ashley
fan I think he knows it I've always been
so inspired by him I've seen him
commentate uh I've worked alongside him
and I think of course he's a he's a
really strong player was a really strong
player but even his commentary it's it's
been so amazing to watch how he's
changed that the energy that got into
the game it influenced I think so much
of Chess broadcast and Robert I don't
know if you remember this but for me one
of my first commentating experiences was
millionaire chess and a chance that
Maurice gave me uh all the way from
India he called me and you and I covered
that event together and it's one of my
core memories and I enjoyed it so much
and uh yeah I think everyone in chat
everyone here commentating we're all
Maurice Ashley fans mauce you're awesome
except for that one kid in the video
where Maurice slps all the pieces off
the board I feel like I've seen that a
couple of times where he's imitating
Searching for Bobby fiser but uh we are
in the midst of a heated match between
Magnus Carlson and Vladimir fedos so
sorry for distracting I just wanted to
give Maurice that shout out and it's
always great to be joined by him but I
don't think it's always great to be
playing Magnus Carlson when you slip up
in a winning position and you start
kicking yourself that's when Magnus I
feel like he is feeling his most
confident he's probably upset that he
allowed fedos of that play but now he
says I can survive even that terrible
end game and what do we make of this
David there are so many tactics in this
position even without Queens on the
board some loose pawns some open lines
against each king would you say that
Magnus or fedos is happier to be in this
position I think Magnus is happier that
he's still ahead in the match uh because
he really was uh kind of fortunate to
survive that previous game fed deserved
the win there but as you say you cannot
relax against Magnus Carson I was
writing this off as level drawish but
not drawn yet and uh like you say
tactics in the air wow including this
move I was gonna say uh there were
tactics like Bishop takes F2 which would
have walked into a pin on the last move
but Magnus first deflecting away the
black king forcing the king to move in
order to win the black Bishop so
actually a level trade in the end but
Magnus now has the opportunity to
capture this Pawn to hope that he gives
his opponent an isolated pawn something
to work with potentially long term in
the game isolated pawns tend to be weak
in their games with Rooks so um okay
mixed feelings here Magnus he could if
he's feeling safe just Retreat his Rook
back but then black will take on his
terms on the C4 Square giving white the
isolated Pawn so um I'm going to stick
to my original evaluation say it should
be a draw with best play but we all know
Magnus that end game touch those end
game skills um fed still needs to bring
his best in order to counter and uh I
suggest starting with a rook move to win
this Pawn yeah don't take it back with
the pawn he plays it and uh he keeps the
Integrity of his Pawn chain intact
connected pawns tend to be better than
isolated ones um Tanya draw prediction
here or am I wrong I really like that
last move by feder I think it's a key
move to keep the balance going and look
at this Magnus makes sure that he can
really trade on D5 on his terms get that
isolated Queen pawn something to play
for long term game one that Magnus W it
was it was the Queens got traded early
on and yet he kept fighting he got the
dub in and this one as well I have no
doubts that he's going to try and create
something the one thing that white is
aiming for is to force black to take on
D5 the bishop falls back to D6 Rook goes
to G5 G7 is hanging this is getting
tactical because black has yet to
capture on D5 feros Robert he needs to
be careful right now and we see that
there's only one move here that holds
the balance for black Rook to H7 it's a
very natural move protecting your Pawn
next to your king that's loose and
keeping contact with the H5 Pawn so
fedos of I mean he just outplayed Magnus
in an end game so I know that I often
lead the charge talking about how strong
Magnus is in the end game and it is true
fedos of I mean he had his chances and
maybe he have chances in this one but
while he sits and thinks why don't we
zoom out for a second because we could
have a winners bracket finalist after
this game on the left hand side of our
screen Dennis lavic is up one and a half
to half two and points sees you sail
through and with the black pieces in
this position oh David I'm looking at
this one I'm thinking I would love to
have the space that Dennis has been able
to secure for
himself he's W Connect Four my favorite
game other than chess he's got this
phenomenal porn chain and uh this porn
chain not only is it beautiful but it
blunts this uh this dark Square Bishop
this I'm I mean calling it a bishop
feels wrong somehow doesn't roll off the
tongue when a piece like This One S
sadly staring down at a bunch of Pawns
also looking at the white king it's not
going to feel safe anytime it can no
longer CLE King side the white Rook has
moved on G1 doesn't really feel
comfortable castling on the other flank
either because you've pushed a pawn out
to B4 meaning the king will be really
Airy long term so I like his space
Dennis lavic my question Tanya what does
white try to do to break the bind to
break this connect for porn
formation it's really hard they say that
to break a bon chain you have to attack
the base but the base is far behind on
C7 it's so hard to get to that you are
thinking about ideas like perhaps A4
expanding on the queen side maybe an
eventual B5 B6 we will see that pawn
chain the base being into trouble but
right now the first thing that Jose has
to think about is taking care of the
king side his own King position as well
and I like this move by Dennis he gets
rid of the active Bishop that was on B3
the light Squad Bishop with White's King
in the center Dennis is not only eyeing
the king Side Advance but a potential D5
break to really start asking questions
white isn't feeling safe on the queen
side with the pawns Advanced once D5
comes in the center opens up as well so
Bishop B6 D5 ideas in the air I'm liking
Black's position here Robert one reason
I would potentially refrain from D5 even
though I think objectively it's a great
move is it does give white a little bit
more breathing room that White's pieces
are cramped and he goes for D5 and the
evaluation bar it doesn't react so I as
you said as I said great decision it's a
very strong move from Dennis but I think
practically speaking then now some of
White's pieces will get a little bit
more space because when you're cramped
you want to trade so I would take this
Pawn on D5 try to quickly put my knight
on e4 and at least I start to see space
some ideas some threats Dennis doesn't
mind T you didn't mind either and David
well now the question is what do you
think about that latest decision are you
also a fan like Tanya and Dennis
himself I say
well I would say yes but it's all about
this bishop um I think here um I still
fa black I think all of us would purely
because of this piece purely because of
the fact that the white king can't
Castle but uh I'm quing two mins Robert
you probably heard the hesitation on my
voice because at least now white has one
compensating factor it's a beautiful
Outpost uh on e4 one that you can never
really challenge um so yeah it's kind of
mixed feelings it feels like denn is a
bit impatient now he senses the
Finishing Line in this match he's one
point ahead a win with black here would
end it on the spot no need to go the
distance in the fourth game and he's
trying to rush but he doesn't need to
he's got the long-term Advantage he has
to just ensure now that white isn't able
to for example push this Pawn forward
move this Rook out the way relocate this
bishop to a new diagonal it's going to
take four five moves but uh Dennis
cannot allow the opponent that luxury
and okay another question mark attached
to this move I think it's actually quite
a healthy one the Knight on the rim
wasn't great but uh now what what is the
idea what's he going to do if white
simply sets up this barricade of Pawns T
do you like it as much as you did just
two three moves ago for black I'm going
to be honest I thought it was an idea
that you want to prepare a little bit
first get your Rook into the game
perhaps transfer the knight from C6 to a
better Square maybe bring back the
Knight on H5 then has decided to go for
it immediately and this E4 Square it
really looks like a stronghold right now
looks like everything is under control
that said I'm still surprised with the
question mark awarded to Knight to F6
because feels like the most natural move
the Knight on H5 isn't doing anything
you want to trade off your opponent's
most active piece in the center David F3
on the board and the big question is how
does black follow up to me it looks
natural that you want to start placing
the Rooks into the center of the board
you want to get one Rook to d8 you want
to get the other Rook to E8 but then you
have to watch out for ideas like B5
meanwhile Dennis just decides to get rid
of the minor
pieces if you take with the Knight I
think he wants to jump in with Knight D5
Knight E3 sor sorry I was just quickly
going to note that the other game
between Magnus Carlson and Vladimir FV
has concluded as a draw there wasn't
much to it a few pieces came off Magnus
still sitting in his chair probably
looking over that opening before getting
into the next game using that game
review feature but for fedos I think
when he clicks on game review he'll say
all right I played like a boss nearly
perfect chess from the black side he was
never in danger so all of our attention
will be back to the left hand side of
our screen between Jose Martinez and
Dennis lazic at least until the fourth
game because there will be a fourth game
between Magnus and Vladimir but for now
I'm starting to see Jose with some
chances I know the evaluation bar is
suggesting that Dennis is still in
charge but I just don't feel like the
last couple moves have gone his way so
David I mean do you see any specific
plans that black can execute to sort of
punish White's King in the center or is
White's King actually going to feel safe
and sound or whoa apparently there was a
big blunder whoa wow double question
mark and we see it we're given a big
clue here by the computer the blue arrow
black can pretty much win on the spot he
needs to pounce now it's a one off
opportunity Dennis look at that on
camera frowning Jose Martinez shaking
his head they both spotted this Knight
takes pawn and let's show this on the
board if it happens this is quite simple
tactics here now I think a bunch of
moves win but this is a simple pin
you've bagged a couple of Pawns in the
process if white tries to defend then
you unleash the bishop this beast from a
far Pawn to E4 and uh the bishop uncaged
simply wins material you're going to win
either the White Knight or the white
rook in the corner this is resign and
it's simple tactics Jose
Martinez let it slip and there we go
it's on the board Knight takes C3 look
at that sips his water Dennis lazovic
double exclamation mark from the game
review
he's just a simple as that I was about
to say things have got better for white
the best position he's seen in a long
time but not that move a big blunder
there Rook to H1 too slow you always
have to be vigilant for tactics these
one-off shots and there we go
resignation game over not an Abrupt
finish to this match it's game over and
it's match over Dennis lazovic advances
through while for Jose Martinez he will
go down to the losers bracket and what a
turnaround it has been for the
17-year-old he was in big trouble the
one big Miss in game one he blundered
but being resourceful held on to that
one and he wins game three Knight
tactics all around Knight G6 got him the
first win Knight C3 got him the second
win what a performance it has been so
far in the cheser bow Masters by Dennis
lavic we have our first Winner's
finalist Dennis lazic the 17-year-old he
continues his resounding success from a
year ago he wins his match against Jose
Martinez two and half half meanwhile on
the rightand side Magus Carlson still
has a game four against feda Vladimir he
proved Pro that in game two he could get
the upper hand with white we'll see if
he can do it a second time but David how
impressed are you with 17-year-old
Dennis
Lai he might just be on the edge of 17
but he is a phenomenon just the killer
instinct spotting that tactic within a
few seconds you saw the frown that kind
of look of confusion on Dennis's face
kind of disbelieving that his strong
grandmas opponent would blunder but the
confidence with which to execute that
tactic to force resignation he's not
lost game yet since division one started
he's uh yeah just amazing amazing player
maybe a future world champion if he
keeps up this uh this type of form but
first we do have another clash in the
winners bracket and I believe that's
about to start soon yeah in just a
couple of minutes Magnus Carlson and
fedia will take on their final rapid
game but the boy of the moment has to be
Dennis lavic we've been talking about
his strategic strength how good he is at
end games how good he is in his opening
preparation positional fights but today
we've seen that when Dennis gets those
tactical opportunities he can be super
sharp Robert is it fair to say that he's
developing into a player who has a very
Universal style I I think that Dennis
lazaric he's known for his opening
prowess he has a sound repertoire and a
very high level one I think there's been
a lot of comparisons to him as being
Wesley so 2.0 he doesn't take risks but
he is able to strike if you give him the
opportunity and so lazic he is improving
he is growing before our very eyes and
he has become a top level Grandmaster in
the Champions chess tour and now he
awaits the winner of this match between
Vladimir fedos and Magnus Carlson and we
are off in game
four we're off and fetv needs to strike
it's a must-win game for him David he
starts with the white pieces it's a
nimso take it away it's a nimzo Indian
defense where black brings out the
bishop very early and now Magnus
challenging for the center uh White's
last move putting the queen on the C2
Square isn't regarded as the most
ambitious the most kind of aggressive
Line This is more positional so bit of a
surprise there and a trade of Pawns in
the center we're heading back towards
one of those carsbad type structures and
it looks like a m mix uh mish mash I was
going to say between the nimzo Indian
and the Queen's Gambit declined and uh
there we go the white Bishop just
exerting pressure now along this
diagonal an awkward pin will Magnus
break the pin that's the big question if
he does he would do that with the move
Pawn to G5 but that would be risky in a
situation he just needs a draw um Robert
do you have any experience in this exact
position if so do you think this is a
good opening Choice by fed I think it is
I think this type of position is
definitely up his alley something he
enjoys and look at Magnus he understands
what's called for not often do we enjoy
bring our Knight out in front of the
pawns but this is the trendy main line
where black goes after this bishop on G3
Pawn to H4 threatens to more or less
trap that Bishop it can't go forward to
E5 but you capture it and if you save
this bishop by pushing H Pawn yourself
up to H4 then the Black Knight jumps
into E4 so I have seen this opening a
number of times it's a very tricky line
I think it's a bit too forcing though
and that's going to be the problem for
Vladimir it doesn't create complications
in a way that more difficult for Magnus
to navigate and you see Magnus he kind
of has like a you know frown on his face
for a second but I think it's just
because he's uncomfortable in his chair
not in the position Tanya I think we're
seeing Knight E4 next for
Magnus we're gonna see the knight jump
onto E4 and then the bishop land on F5
right now white needs to answer the
question with that Bishop on G3 hanging
you really don't want to recapture with
the F Pawn opening up the E file the E3
weakness he falls back with the bishop
now black has the opportunity for Magnus
he can jump on with Bishop F5 lining up
the bishop and the Knight and the queen
with potential ideas of discovered
attacks and I think for white you've got
to develop that Bishop from F1 on D3 if
black was to play Bishop F5 David fully
agree white is actually behind in
development now white has just been
messing around with this bishop it's
moved several times White's Queen a bit
of a Target as you indicated Tanya um
but on the bright side you've provoked
the black pawns forward Black's never
going to feel entirely safe with the
king in the center or on the king side
and Magnus in the meantime a bit of a
mysterious move I'm going to say is he
lining up some tactics against the white
king potentially in the center Black's
pieces flying out of the traps here
Black's Bishop wants to move as you
mentioned black wants to Castle on the
queen side as Magnus did successfully in
an earlier game but yeah this is uh
chaotic and I was skeptical at first
I've got to say this uh solid opening
Choice from fed but it's really come to
life Magnus is uh not backed down from
the fight here and suddenly Black's Pawn
structure might might well be ruined in
the next few turns um I just wonder
where the black king is going to go
where's the white king going to go kind
of lined up all directions all these
pieces against it um this is a fiery
really promising start to this game
Robert um already I see so many tactics
in the air I guess you do too oh it's
going to be a fun battle for these two
but they still are within the realm of
some predecessor games in fact U Yi the
super Grand Master From China played
against Gregory Oparin who is a very
powerful player in his own right and a
renowned theoretician so the bishop went
out to B5 in this game a little bit more
aggressive both Kings remain in the
center and there are a lot of loose
pieces in particular the Knight on C6
and then the White Knight on C3 so yeah
they're attack this in the air for sure
it looks scary for both sides there's
also Pawn tension between H4 and G5 at
any moment one of those pawns can be
captured so I am going to pass I'm just
going to talk about all these ideas and
say it's wild time
I mean this looks scary for both but I
think maybe a little scarier for
white absolutely agree especially with
that last move Bishop F5 we've been
talking about this and I just want to
point out one of the tactics that are
possible we mentioned that white wants
that Bishop on D3 when black plays
Bishop F5 but now that Magnus has a
queen on E7 if you play Bishop D3
actually unpinning that Knight on C6
there might be big tactics Knight takes
D4 is the first move that comes to mind
you want to open up e takes D4 the queen
on E7 is suddenly the power piece knight
takes C3 maybe there are better checks
in the position but Knight C3 looks like
it would be game over so in fact fosa
does not have the option to counter this
last move by Magnus with retreating his
own Bishop but David if that's if that's
not on the table how are you fighting
the threat of a night jump fos doesn't
care he literally doesn't care he plays
a moving Knight to E2 and wow this is is
a a big high responsibility move I
guessed the idea just before uh we move
away from the analysis is if Knight to
G3 which looks really strong double
attack against the White Queen and
against this rook in the corner then
white will take off this Knight and if
you recapture White Queen jumps out and
it's counter attack time remember this
Knight is hanging if you take this Rook
then the White Queen actually feasts on
this rook in the corner due to a double
attack so this is uh kind of the essence
of chess the essence of tactics are all
these double attacks and this is kind of
the epitome this is kind of um a great
demonstration of where all the tactics
start flying and um this current
position I actually think Magnus needs
to first take care of his King before he
gets too ambitious with any tricks traps
of his own um I wonder whether that's
just dodging getting the king to a safer
square off this diagonal I wonder
whether that's biting the bullet
castling into it as we say getting the
King hidden on the long side but either
way this is really really heating up and
uh what a what a start for us he takes
this porn instead on H 4 and now the
blue arrow strikes again Pawn to A3
that's by far one of the most difficult
moves I'm going to say it looks like you
just want to get to safety with your
king a slow pawn move Robert is that
surprising yeah it's surprising because
black has like five different options
that all look scary for white to handle
including Knight on e4 takes Knight on
C3 so this position is very tricky I
said it before and I'll say it again I
think it's trickier for white just
because many of the tactics are
seemingly hitting for in Black's favor
whereas white doesn't have that many
threats just the Knight on C6 that can
be piled up on so A3 good luck to you
and I just want to not one more
defensive move that black always has is
that Rook coming up to H6 or in this
case we see the blue arrow castling
Queen so David that was your suggestion
before and apparently it's the only move
that keeps the edge for
black W castling Queen side it's brave
but it's got to be on his radar this
multiple threats here including Queen
takes Pawn on D5 and castling Queen side
does defend against that it takes a
brave man though Tanya a brave player to
uh just kind of commit the King on a
side that is going to be wrecked ruined
in the near future this is such a
difficult position it's just so
complicated and to come to a decision
right now it is already a moment where
you need to start being precise as we've
seen Queen B3 not an accurate move but
from a practical perspective it asks
questions I really like this idea that
you mentioned Robert of actually a rook
lift on the king side because I would
hate to destroy that pawn structure on
the queen side I want to go long Castle
eventually but whenever you take on C6
you want to recapture with that Rook but
the question is does black have enough
time can Ashley black make the move Rook
eight say just postponing castle for the
sake of the structure here
David possible but I'm reluctant to give
up the uh beautiful D Pawn the White
Queen then would be attacking this
bishop as well like you said time I
think that is the key word right now and
that's why moves like Castle's Queen
side kind of long-term strategically
they're risky they don't make that much
sense but it's all about saving time and
Castle's Queen side achieves multiple
things in one go you get your king to
safety Magness plays it you protect your
Pawn on D5 everything at once and you
unpin your knight now big threats of
jumping out this way maybe Knight A5 in
the near future um only now does fed say
have challenged the black bishop and
okay this one if feels like this is
going to be decided somehow by a
tactical shot Robert I'm not sure where
I'm not sure when it might not be for
another 15 20 moves but it's that type
of position there are so many tactics in
the air and one of them is Tanya's idea
from earlier there are Knight takes D4
ideas that you have to be careful about
so Bishop takes Knight on C3 would be my
first step because the E file if that
knight from the white side gets out the
way there will be a direct shot so look
at Magnus he Scoops up this Knight here
FV he has to take with the pawn if he
takes with the Knight he loses and and
he does just that but let's talk about
an open G file why don't we discuss that
a rook can slide to G8 now or in the
near future if you want to keep your
Pawn structure intact I already
mentioned a move like Rook H6 which not
only defends the queen side but allows
you to double on the G file in a
creative way so I think that you can
make multi-purpose moves here if you're
Magnus Carlson I don't believe in
White's attack I don't think the black
king is in real danger and I think that
the scorecard underneath the board here
one exclamatory move from Magnus Queen
side a great reaction and for fedos
sometimes a question mark one error it
doesn't seem like a big one but in a
position where you have to be accurate
every single turn to keep the initiative
it can show that the advantage heads in
one player's way and in this case it's
Magnus so I yeah I don't really know how
Magnus is going to respond here he has
several options but I just don't really
believe in any attack against the black
king T he's touching the 4minute mark so
he needs to make a decision quick
because there are still a lot of pieces
on the board and there's still a lot of
fight in this position left I completely
agree with you that now white doesn't
will not be probably given the chance to
actually destroy the pawn structure on
the queen side again I really like the
idea of Rook H6 and I think it's just
been played by Magnus really nice call
there just a really good concept that
you know we often think about developing
Rooks uh you want to move them sideways
but Rook lifts in these kind of
positions can be so multi-purpose you're
thinking about not only defending that
Knight on C6 but eventually attacking
White's kingside pawns for fetv his King
is feeling very unsafe I can't imagine a
safety on the queen side the F2 Pawn is
hanging King side looks equally
dangerous which doesn't only mean that
the king is unsafe but it also means
that the Rook on H1 remains out of the
game for a really long time here
David I I don't envy fed at all I think
the only thing going in White's favor
now is the clock um I was going to
comment on his camera he was leaning
back for a long time he looked a bit
kind of out of love with his position
and understandably so but he needs to
hustle um Magnus he's so hard to kind of
throw off balance he's you see it
sometimes you see Magnus get emotional
you see him shaking his head but it's so
rare you really have to kind of shock
him with a move even if it's not the
best move just throw something uh kind
of throw a spanner in the works but
suddenly it's all lining up and it's not
turning out well for white he's kind of
forced Magnus to play a move he wanted
clock situation is dramatic Magnus is
lower there but it feels like White's
position is so much harder to play than
the opponents and but I'm trying to find
some reason for fed to get optimistic
must admit I'm struggling do you see any
in this position do you think he looks
uh happy at
all no he's definitely not happy because
he needs to win this game just to stay
alive up in the winners bracket if he
loses he's still in the tournament
that's the good news but we saw the
sharks that are down in the losers
bracket we watched Ali Raza fuja and Yan
pishi make it through so it's not like
you know you get to the losers bracket
and suddenly things are easier and as
for the chess he makes a pawn push Pawn
to F3 and we saw the blue arrow it comes
back to us I don't even think that's the
only move here like if I'm being honest
I think that black has a number of moves
that keep him with a huge advantage and
a draw is good enough for Magnus he's
got the odds here so he could play it
safe he could play aggressively and of
course Tanya he finds the best move even
when there are five different
good-looking options Magnus Carlson just
always seems to find the best move moves
in positions I don't know how he does it
but to me it looks like it was game
three which was fed's big Chance missing
that opportunity with that Knight coming
back in that night and pawn end game I
think it was game two I'm sorry I'm
going to correct myself game two with
Knight E4 um and eventually giving up
the night for that Aon moving forward
that was a golden opportunity missed by
FV and against the world number one when
you missed those opportunities they come
far few and rare it's very hard to
bounce back in this match and now now
this position it's Magnus who's playing
for
more yeah I have to agree and we saw
Magnus on the camera kind of Shifting
position again frowning wincing I think
he might be remembering game two as well
Tanya just uh these top players they're
such perfectionists um they want to kind
of have smooth sailing they want to have
bragging rights over the opponent but
look at this Magnus suddenly upping the
pace maybe he was just shifting position
suddenly he's going for this white king
and the pawn is going to capture on G2
any moment now and it's really
reminiscent of that game earlier where
fua was able to Checkmate his opponent
with a king out in the open um I really
really fear for fed's Life credit to Fed
Poker Face there on the camera but after
Pawn takes G2 attacking this rook in the
corner the white king is going to be
Shan of its protection and there's going
to be all sorts of sacrifices in the air
I'm looking at the F3 Square I'm looking
at this bishop jumping in later to E4 um
there are threats on white side um it's
all about the clock now for Magnus maybe
there's a a lot to calculate right now
but definitely winning for black if he
can hold his nerve if he can uh can
maintain this level of accuracy we've
shown Robert White wow okay gives up the
in the corner do you think we'll see an
under promotion we have seen it yes that
is always fun to play in a game and it
was necessary everyone because you have
to count Tempo by Tempo if you establish
a new Queen there you would lost both of
your Queens so he had to take and
promote to a knight because it's a check
and then he can save his Queen so just
David is showing this would have won for
white because both Queens would have
left the board so what a find by fedos
and a quick response from Magnus I think
fedos is doing the right thing when you
are in a winner go down to losers
bracket moment you need to throw
everything at Magnus and at least we
have an imbalance and you Magnus has
been grimacing throughout this game
White's King feels a little bit safer so
when there's a lot at stake in each and
every game players do go wrong from time
to time even Magnus Carlson the number
one player of well more than the last
decade so as I look at this position
Tanya I see that black is well ahead the
evaluation bar it's not lying to us but
do you see any chances for white just
because we do have some material
imbalances and perhaps play in a
different direction the biggest chance
of fedos would have been if Magnus had
the auto promote to queen turned on in
that moment Z have captured on H1 and
that would have changed the game but an
under motion gets the job done Magnus
Carlson is up in exchange he's already
up on the score line he uh is dominating
this game from start to finish it looks
like fedos with the white pieces never
really got going on the queen side we
see no attack against Black's King white
King's still feeling a bit of pressure
the Knight falls back the F for Bishop
cannot be given up uh but I do see the
bishop on D3 lining up with a rook on G6
David is this more complicated than what
meets the eye at first I think so I
think uh yes it's complicated and yes
it's imbalanced that's the key for fed
he cannot let it be just a clear-cut
kind of a straight linear variation that
Magnus has to work out and then it's
over and then it's a draw or a black win
he has to make it as we mentioned
earlier a bit muddy those Waters he has
to complicate the issue and um I do love
the white Bishops I'm very biased my
favorite piece those Bishops magnus's
favorite pieces I'll give a secret there
but uh in the meantime okay Rook to G5 a
really classy move and uh if Rooks
disappear I do fear for fed then he's
just trying to again simplify the
equation Magnus Carson and Rook to H6
the bar slides down Robert what's
happened here uh is this a necessary
kind of gamble by fed what's he missed
it is yeah he knew that if he traded
Rooks he had no winning chances so he'd
rather lose he wants to go down swinging
the Black Knight can step back to E7
trades clearly favor Magnus Carlson
who's AE by material and has the safer
King so you're removing Defenders from
the white side so this is it gets a
question mark because objectively it was
a bad move it hands white excuse me
black a winning Advantage but it you
have to do it because a draw is a loss
so I think that he made the right
decision and what in the world is
that wow double question Mar Magnus
Carlson what's he missed is he just
trying to simplify things he's not
losing evaluation bus says still better
for black but I see the look of shock on
your
face yeah I just saw the evalar rise up
we see that it's a blunder it looks like
a stunning move the idea is clear right
if white was to pick up the Knight on D4
he wants to take the Knight on F5 you
recapture with the bishop the queen
jumps onto the game it still looks
incredibly strong for black with the
Rook so active the queen on F5 the
bishop on G3 not really getting the job
done and look at this the computer says
the best move for white is actually not
to grab material to allow the activity
but actually just to push the pawn on F4
that was must be what mnus missed rber
well I think this is hilarious the best
move here is not even to take the
sacrific material but is push your Pawn
to shut in your own Bishop but that
shows how sad fed's position is and that
actually means that magnus's decision it
deserves exclamation points not question
marks because what is F4 here he might
play it but where are the winning
chances possibly going to come from for
v no one's playing F4 here I'm sorry
nobody's for here what was that oh my
gosh oh that was commentated I'm putting
it on
that oh David you are you as surpris as
Tanya that he played F4 yes I'm glad
Tanya you jumped in before me one more
second and I would have said the same so
don't worry and F4 is such an ugly
positional move but it's based on
tactical reasons The Rook is trapped and
I think this is what Magnus
underestimated this is why that we saw
the bar sink even the one world number
one is human he didn't spot in advance
that The Rook could actually be left on
this Square F4 is a really classy move
but ultimately as the computer's
pointing out here King to B8 the Blue
Arrow showing that black is still fine
you just need to shuffle into the corner
always step towards the corner if you
Castle on the long side if you Castle
Queen side good tip for everyone but
still this is uncomfortable I'm gonna
say for Magnus Carson 40 seconds on the
clock a trapped Rook suddenly for the
first real time since we jumped in here
the nerves are going to be jangling
Magnus he's going to try and Focus he
plays the best move of course he does he
is the best for a reason but it's going
to be uncomfortable he's got to untangle
this piece is a big problem long term
and Robert he's going for it now
fev and Magnus must have some kind of
attack against the white king and the
problem is the queen can't jump over the
Rook so I'm looking at Rook takes that
forward check some kind of sacrifice of
The Rook to go after the white king
they're not my pieces so I can give them
up and take it back but Magnus he's down
under 20 seconds he needs to find
something because f was threatening to
win
material wow and suddenly he goes for
that idea Robert he's given up a whole
Rook Magnus Carson but he's gambling
he's got 20 seconds left now Magnus is a
whole piece down wow suddenly this is
turned he's living life on the edge the
world number one fed this is his
opportunity he drops back his King that
was a check now the black Rook surely is
going to dive into the position and uh
Magnus Stakes a high 15
seconds he's lost control he has lost
control Magnus
on 10 seconds now and the good news of
FV is that the bishop can block the
check on the second rank so you don't
end up losing material and there's no
back rank ideas because the Knight is
defending instead of The Rook check
Magnus gives a queen check but white is
up a whole piece right now you could
also snap up the Knight on E7 it's a
piece for three pawns and the white king
is out but Magnus he went down to just
about one or two seconds and barely got
his moves off so the I see the
evaluation white is favored that is
clear but it's still within that drawing
territory for Magnus he is mad but FV is
locked in trying to find a way to go
after the black king or maybe to checkm
on the back rank was to WR a queen
Sacrifice from
Vladimir wow that was beautiful let's
just back try it very quickly one move
Rook takes Queen was not a good idea
because white would have landed a back
ranker a back spanker here uh that would
have been checkmates so Queen G5 he's
going for the end game Magnus Carson to
take or not to take what do we think
should he keep the Queens on the board
it's a tough one do you try to attack
Black's King on the queen side where do
you find the entry point he decides not
to trade moves are coming in fast and
quick fast here White's King is weak so
normally you would want to trade off
Queens but fed needs to win he cannot
risk the Game fizzling out towards a
draw again Magnus begging for the queen
trade and uh he's still fighting
evaluation B say only small Advantage
here for white it's all about the pawns
Robert he's lacking pawns right now and
great understanding no surprise there
from Magnus Carlson if the Queens come
off he says I can hold because a pawn
chain is as strong as its base Pawn
without the Queens on the board it's
difficult for white to make inroad so we
see another queen trade being offered
but Magnus does need to be a bit careful
there could be a moment where he offers
a queen trade at an inopportune time and
thus allows white to transition into a
nearly winning ending so for now he has
everything under control Tanya I don't
see how white makes progress
here well he's moving the king he's
saying I want to trade on my turns where
the king will find a spot on D4 the good
news for fedos it's very hard for Magnus
to get rid of the C5 and the A3 pawns as
long as the pawns are on the board white
will have good winning chances the king
is advancing from A5 to B6 locking down
magnus's Rook on on the eighth rank to
stop checkmating ideas Magnus can't
allow White's King to be6 steps up with
The Rook one pawns picked up I think
fedos is going to get the job done in
this one I see the evalar is equal but
David practically it's got to be really
difficult to hold got to be difficult to
hold but the big question does Magnus
Carson believe in fortresses we've heard
the answer a million times he originally
said no but he he is relying on one
right now the black king stops the white
king from coming in and uh if you hold
your line maybe it's tough okay a check
now trying to deflect the white king
away he's trading pawns he's getting the
job done Magnus I was agreeing Tanya I
thought white had great winning chances
but not against an endgame Genius Like
Magnus Carson suddenly black is getting
closer and closer to safety all he needs
to do is eliminate the remaining white
porn from the board and uh Robert it
looks like he's done everything right
Magus although fedos sa still has
chances because we do know that if all
three of Black come off we well there's
no way fedos is going to make a draw by
repetition here he he's going to play on
until the very end because he does have
an extra P so yes rook and Bishop versus
Rook everyone theoretical draw but when
you have no time on the clock good luck
to save it but for now I mean Magnus is
not giving any ground
David building up time on the clock as
well Magnus had one or two seconds a
while back suddenly Magnus is up at 15
16 seconds he's really up the pace
really upped his game and uh fed he'll R
another missed opportunity if this one
slips away he won a piece he tricked
Magnus in that time scramble but
suddenly look at the black Rook just uh
lining up pinning or attacking harassing
the white pieces and okay we see the
final white Pawn disappear so this is a
draw even if black loses his remaining
two points but that is difficult and the
black king is caught on the edge of the
board so there will be checkmating
patterns um let's predict now will
Magnus hold it might be difficult but
will he do
it I'm going to predict a big yes on
this one I mean what the position was
and what he's managed to get just his
resourcefulness in this end game has
been just incredible to watch putting
that King on A7 it felt like a fortress
then at the right time managing to
exchange trade off those remaining white
pawns and now for FV he's got to try to
push this position but Magnus has enough
time on the clock Robert I'm predicting
this one to end in a draw what about you
and of course should be a draw but look
at what fedos is doing Magnus King is
caught on the side of the board and if
Magnus ever has to push his pawns then
those pawns become weaker Magnus looks
bored he's like I can do this in my
sleep but what fedos he's determined and
this could
be type of position where White does get
the upper hand takes one Pawn then the
second and then you have to prove it
over 50 turns for everyone at home a 50
moves without a capture or a pawn push
result in a draw and that's what Magnus
is relying on in fact when was the last
Pawn push does anyone
know a long time ago we'll go back and
count I think the last capture was a
bunch of moves ago 15 20 moves already
so Magnus is getting closer it's the old
Captain America line I could do this all
day he's defending really resolutely
here and he's got his King off the edge
of the board look at this diamond
formation the black pawns and King here
um but going to hold these pawns
together that's for sure F to say he's
got a few more moves Robert as you
mentioned he's got to win one of the
black pawns or push them forward force
them provoke them forward in order to
keep the game alive he's running out of
time though both on board and clock not
making any progress surely now as we
reach 100 moves this one is edging
closer to the
draw so hard to beat Magnus Carlson it's
unbelievable it reminds me of the
Toronto finals where Magnus against
Fabby he was down a queen and he managed
to win that one and here he was down a
piece and it looked like f have did
everything to get his chances he strik
when it mattered and then eventually
Magnus just with his resourcefulness
manages to hold this end game the pawns
haven't moved one hasn't been captured
we are getting closer to the 50 move and
it looks like it might not even go into
a rook Bishop versus Rook d I say it
this is a fortress and there's been no
way for fedos to make progress because
the Rook on C4 it defends and prevents
the white king from joining the party so
what a hold from Magnus but what play
from fedos he should hold his head high
even if this game ends as a draw and he
goes down to the losers bracket because
if one little move went differently he
could have tied this match and maybe if
a couple things had gone a different way
he would have tied it earlier and had
some different
chances the countown begins 10 more
moves 10 moves to get to the 50 move R
and it will be a draw unless white wins
upon or one of the black pawn moves
Tanya I think he's wow just before it
happens Pawn to D4 why did Magnus break
the formation he got impatient on the
brink of a
draw that was a bad choice do it he just
had eight more moves to go he's making
his moves with half a second on his clap
look at his time he's barely getting his
moves off and he's dropping his Pawns
and Magnus knows it he's not happy with
his decisions one Pawn goes the 50 move
has been reset and fedos chances are
back just as we were saying he's on the
brink of a draw it was the 10 move
countdown if he did nothing for 10 moves
it would have been over by now but it's
the clock it was the Panic it was uh
just that Restless desire to do
something the human nature and now
suddenly this black porn in the center
is not going to survive that much longer
it might get uh coralled it might get uh
surrounded at some point the black king
will be driven away still a lot of work
to be done but now feder he's goingon to
be gaining in confidence look at Magnus
you're right Robert just every move he's
getting off with two three seconds left
he's really feeling the nerves now he's
only Human After
All another song lyric dropped in there
from David I appreciate you but I think
that the white king it needs to get
active and Magnus still doing a good job
of keeping the white king Tethered to
the bishop not allowing it to cross the
third rank satanya I mean the move count
it started again on move 117 we are
currently on move
138 are we going to see that pawn drop
off or is Magnus going to be able to
hold this position and not allow any
more trades he's got to try and do it
but it was really surprising how he let
the move counter reset with that move d4
lost the pawn fetv has to look for his
chances to win that D4 pawn and then try
and fight it in a rook Bishop versus
Rook the main idea is to push magnus's
King into some kind of a meting net but
step one has to be to grab that D4 Pawn
but the first question how do you even
bring the king out of that second rank
uh situation that Magnus has trapped it
into David do you see progress for
White's King here I see progress with a
helping hand but unfortunately again
you're playing Magnus Carson and he is a
Marathon Man whoa Magnus Carson lost on
time are you kidding
me no way oh my
goodness Magnus Carlson gets
flagged unbelievable
fedos gets it done he gets the dub he
comes back it goes into armagen I am in
utter disbelief but persistence pays off
for fedos of I know Magnus represents
Mission zero but he didn't want 0
seconds on his clock it is 2 to2 Magnus
he went away but he has another game to
play all of a sudden I cannot believe
that Magnus carlsson just lost on time
it reminds me of his final game in the
uh Champions chestor as world champion
against yaru Nakamura where he moused up
his Queen how can this possibly happen
to the best player on the
planet this is unreal we're all reeling
in from this while Dennis lazovic
advances through Magnus Carlson has got
to fight it out in the armagedon Magnus
Carlson getting flagged you don't get to
see that David I'm out of words I think
we all need a quick break before this
armor gon starts we will have the bids
really soon Magus needs to recover we
all need to recover don't go anywhere
we'll be back in just a
[Music]
few
you're on a train or on a plane or you
go completely off grid with chess's
offline mode you can now study chess
anytime anywhere and not miss a day of
training and when you're back online you
just synchronize and everything is
updated
automatically
we're going to play blindfold blitz so
I'm actually going to get up right now
and I'm going to blindfold him all right
this is you know nothing weird is going
to happen here trust me there you go
close your eyes right I'm going to move
the pieces for you so all you got to do
is just say the move and I'm going to
move the pieces for him I'm going to
start your clock you just say your move
and hit your clock so okay play one V3
okay okay so he plays B3 I'm going to
play Knight F6 Bishop
B2
G6 Knight
F3 Bishop G7
F4 F4 yep he got a good position all
right Knight takes D4 Queen takes D4
check Knight to F6 Queen E3 I think
you're doing great just so if you're
worried yeah that it looks like a very
boring position
why am I struggling so much with the
right thing to play here um my plan now
is just to try to flag GE Queen to be6
good move I have 2 minutes and 24
seconds you have 4 minutes and 45
seconds I mean I should have given you
minutes all right I know I know I'm old
and slow you're not for to
hit all right I'm play Rook to d8 I'll
play Rook uh
F
D1 you play a lot of good chess moves
has I ever told you
that no h hold a freaking draw here come
on Dan all right Rook takes D1 yeah Rook
takes
Rook I got to do what I need to do to
win you got to do what you got to do to
win got to respect it Knight to F6 ah
what are you doing you training
something I was like uh King to
E3 why did you have to see it it was
one Rook to D Rook to D1 D D1 yeah I
feel you Daddy good
ah I I'll play Rook to
C4 okay Bishop to
D5 I'll play Rook to
fe3 Wesley this is your chance to
blunder you can do it Rook to G1
mhm Bush
A5 no more mate Rook to G1 B to
E4 oh man was an accurate move Bishop to
a
B7 okay I'm just kidding I let go on A8
I can't do I can't take advantage of a
blind
man I'm getting M it I'm getting M it
King to G7 uh why why are you running
that was a good move by me it's not over
yet Knight E8 check
I'm going to play the most boring King
to
F7 Arrow takes Bishop A6 it Wesley yeah
King takes E8 King King
E6 King to f8 all King the
F oh wow that hurts actually that's a
big time oh I lost on time that was a
big time I will lost trag good time wow
good game I almost feel okay about
myself almost yeah you're doing good for
your first game after a long time
yeah
welcome to the most exciting format in
chess
Armageddon the ultimate tiebreaker
Armageddon grants white more time on on
the clock but in return white must win a
draw secures black the match win white
starts with 10 minutes and each player
submits a confidential bid with an
amount of time they are willing to start
with lowest bid gets to choose their
color usually black in those coveted
draw ODS let the Armageddon
[Music]
commence
in just a few seconds we will have the
Armageddon and the bids are in Magnus
Carlson wins the bid he did go pretty
low with 6 minutes 38 seconds Vladimir
fedia with an 8 minute 30 second bid to
me it looks like David that FV was happy
to get white he did not want to
compromise too much on the time
understandably he just struck with white
he won with white and now he has a few
extra minutes in his pocket Magnus
meanwhile that's a brave brave bid How
Low Can You Go 6 and a half is living
life on the edge especially because he
knows now fed has that recipe of
creating Chaos on the board for better
or worse that last game fed he showed
how to do
it and Robert fed flagged Magnus but he
had the upper hand throughout the game
he was the one who was pushing after the
Miss in the middle game by Magnus and
let's not forget game two as well it
felt like fedf should have got the dub
in this is going to be a big fight where
off and we're seeing a repeat it's the
queen Gambit decline this time well
there are a few things that we can't
forget as the players they shouldn't
forget their opening lines FV he is the
world rapid silver medalist behind
Magnus Carlson he also can play very
long games he doesn't just end them on
the spot so when is Armageddon without
increment you start to worry about the
clock so fedos is using time as a weapon
Magnus he hasn't moved David can you
actually afford to invest this kind of
time at this stage of the game when
you're playing Vladimir
FV you simply cannot you need to adapt
you need to react you need to just trust
your instincts and Magnus actually
sacrifices the pawn big decision here if
this Pawn is captured the Black Knight
jumps into the B4 Square not only is the
Black Knight coming in Via C2 in that
variation but the White Queen might have
been trapped so wisely avoiding the
Temptation greed not being good in this
case but uh you're right Magnus it feels
again right now that he's freezing he
hasn't adapted kind of to this new
Rhythm that he needs
we've I mean I've played Armageddon
we've all seen Armageddon games it's all
about the speed you need to at least get
out of the traps the early stages
opening middle game in good shape on the
clock Magus still has under six minutes
now um but it's going to get scary
especially if white starts throwing
pawns forward this might be the
opportunity for fed go for the black
king complicated because complicated
positions are the hardest to uh navigate
in time trouble he does it g he's going
with the the pawns now towards the black
k Tanya this is scary for Magnus already
G4 H4 on the board you're down by more
than three and a half minutes on the
clock and the game is just getting
started when the king is under Fire no
increment this can get really out of
hand very quick for Magnus I'd already
be scared with this move G5 coming in
Magnus jumps in with the Knight but can
white still think about sacrificing a
Pawn on the king side and he does it he
wants to open the hline the queen is
headed to H5 if black St getting greedy
and this is why the uh you see the blue
arrow F6 the only move to keep the
balance for Magnus Carlson and he
doesn't find it I mean that's not an
easy move to play pushing Pawns in front
of your own King he actually allows the
capture of a Pawn on H6 but then white
would have had a sacrifice material on
C3 so look at fed's response David a
natural play by him defending his Knight
but it was a mistake a missed
opportunity and now Magnus finds that
correct
Choice he said AB he said he said H and
G with his pawns he needed to just
continue the attack just hammer away at
the black king but now it's too late now
black is the one striking uh on the
king's side because actually all of
Black's pieces are in play this Knight
now hit but Black's Bishop x-ray vision
against the king Black's Bishop from
afar the light Bishop as well doing a
great job and this centralized Knight
suddenly he's lost momentum here fed and
that's how quickly things can turn
around suddenly black is the one with
the open file looking at the white king
um I agree but it was almost
imperceptible blink and you miss it but
that one chance the question mark or the
missed opportunity we saw from fed
suddenly things are turning and uh
Magnus at least his moves are flowing
he's really picked up that pace in the
last few moves suddenly he's down to a
three minute time Advantage only for FV
and what a mess we have in front of us
Tanya this is the definition of a real
Mele but with why that's exactly what
you want you want a mess in position
when you're playing against Magnus it is
about those one move opportunity FY have
missed it now Magnus taking his Queen
out also thinking about doubling up on
the F line with the Rook watch out once
Rook from A8 comes to f8 there might be
sacrifices on the bishop on F4 Rook
takes Bishop idea is always in the air
to me it just looks like Black's the one
who's on the attack right now and for
fed that King is going to be stuck in
the center for the rest of the game well
that sounds familiar to me because
that's exactly what happened a game ago
right Magnus was able to go after some
weak King he was able to get his Rooks
involved and yet fedos of still was
surviving and then won so this is a bad
position for white the king is in the
center the black king isn't that unsafe
despite white taking all this time to
pry openen the G file so Magnus he does
need to be careful here because the
queen was staring at his King on G8 and
that's why he kicks that Queen back and
is going to force it to squore like G2 a
little bit more passive and Tanya I love
your idea of doubling Rooks and David I
feel like as we look at this position
where's the attack for white I actually
think that black is the one more likely
to have the attack against the white
kick totally agree if this was anyone
else other than fed I would say this is
really backfired it's really gone wrong
but he has such a wrigly style fed save
I've played him many times myself he
escapes from these weird positions these
awkward looking positions with all the
pieces hanging he's so good at quick
calculation two three move lines he
knows if he doesn't blunder anything
he'll get chances later on and uh it's
like being a sportsman sometimes you
just have to get through a game and take
your chance one you might only get one
or two shots uh just pounce a bit later
as he did in the previous game in the
mus win situation so now Magnus under
four minutes no
increment I starting to believe in fed's
chances even if the white king looks a
bit awkward in the center these piece
trades don't necessarily help black and
they're only going to make uh the game
drag on a bit longer take this bishop
back with the queen why not and then uh
I'm not sure where the white king is
going but then try to line up at least
Poe questions as magnus's clock ticks
down who do you think is the favorite
Armageddon it's only ramping up pressure
now it's such a difficult question and
David while it felt like objectively you
should keep the pieces on the board but
given magnus's time now under four
minutes no increment he's just trying to
ease off the pressure trying to ease the
complications off but I think that only
helps fed like you pointed out it was a
lot harder for the white king as long as
there were more pieces but with these
trades it looks like fedf can breathe a
bit more the bishop falls back to D6 I
like the idea of Rook G1 but again you
always have to watch out for Rook to f8
Rook F4 sacrifices perhaps at some point
Magnus is also eyeing that knight from
A5 suddenly jumping on to C4 with that
last move Bishop D6 it x-rays that
Knight on E5 with the bishop on F4 the
more I look at it I think Knight C4 is a
threat on the board well you know what I
was thinking the bishop G5 If This Were
a bullet game that's what I'm playing
from the white side I'm pinning your
Rook on F6 and I'm just trying to open
the H file and go after the black king I
don't think it works considering the
evaluation bar is still saying black has
the better position but if it did work
it would say white is winning and ho do
I I know my man Vladimir fos he's going
for it he's going for it and we also
know Magnus Carson he will not allow an
attack unless he can calculate his way
through and he actually doesn't play the
best move we saw Miss wow a blunder now
Magnus Carlson I was going to say he
just takes back the pawn sacrifices The
Exchange but what does he missed can
white ignore the threat on this Rook
this looked like a hit but if you ignore
and go for the black Rook instead
he moves it Bishop takes Rook I think
was winning there and going for the
black king wow we might show that a bit
later but Magnus dodged a bullet still
in trouble though as now the bishop
lands on this Square watch out for the
Rook lining up the queen jumping in
magnus's King is living life on the edge
it's been left abandoned by its own
Queen The Black Queen so far offside now
T you think he's just going to check
mate Magnus it's insane how many turn
rounds we're seeing in this matchup it's
just hard to predict anything and
suddenly it looks like white is once
again on the attack David I think the
idea that you were earlier alluding to
give up your Rooks go for that Bishop F6
Queen G6 but it's still in the air Queen
G6 is coming up next how is Magnus
fighting it the queen from A3 cannot
come back into the defense the E7 square
is controlled by the bishop Queen G6 I
think Rook F7 is the defensive resource
here but things looking very dangerous
for Magnus he decides to give up his
exchange I think it's a good try I mean
I think for Magnus this is what David
was suggesting earlier and only one move
keeps the edge for fedos of Rook G6 the
move does make a lot of sense that black
Rook is both a defender of the king and
also an aggressive piece Queen D4 can
hardly fa fedos for this and now Queen
E7 I see the arrows coming in that's an
only move but I think that only move is
Pretty Natural for black to play bring
more pieces to your King's defense
though that A7 Pawn is also loose I
don't really know how both these players
are assessing the position equal doesn't
feel
accurate to me it looks like draw is the
least likely result in this one this is
absolute madus so it doesn't matter what
the evalar says yes you can grab the A7
Pawn but that would give Magnus the time
to bring his Knight into play once that
Knight jumps to C4 DAV I think Magnus
can start looking for tricks on White's
King suddenly this Black Knight sitting
on a beautiful Outpost is going to be
worth just as much as one of the white
Rooks this Rook on C2 not participating
at all so yeah definitely turning around
fed he doesn't know he missed an
opportunity but there was a big one and
suddenly anyone's game the Knight lands
on C4 will he prize open the position
risk it uh by pushing his pawns forward
in the center fed if he wants to open up
the white Rooks but it might also open
up his King you can see on the cameras
fev leaning in now he knows it's about
to become a Time scramble Magna still
two whole minutes down two and a half
minutes with zero increment we've all
played Blitz online on chess.com
it is scary it might come down to
flagging and fed look he's just
preparing a nice home for the white king
he's getting ready for the long game a
bit of a maneuvering battle later he's
trying to prolong this one as much as
possible but a night for in the air uh
Robert who are you favoring here
evaluation bar giving us no clues at all
the knights are trickier pieces so from
the board position I actually like
Black's chances but it's the about the
clock fedos with the white pieces to
start with Magnus with his low bid sure
the def it has been trimmed but this is
scary territory when there's opponent's
rook and queen lined up against your
king and watch out for Pawn breaks
that's what Magnus is trying to avoid
and I love his last couple moves
regrouting the night stopping the the
breaks But Here Come trade offers and
can you afford to liquidate too much if
the Queens come off the board is white
winning is black still within the
drawing range Tanya these are difficult
questions maybe nearly impossible
questions to answer unless you could sit
and think for instead of 20 seconds 20
minutes and the thing is Magnus has been
flagged once today will he be flaged
twice I like that decision by Magnus
though it means you keep more pieces on
the board but taking on F4 would have
opened up the E Line attacking that
Queen giving a lot of activity to the
white Rook as well the Knight jumps back
Knights are tricky I'm going to put both
of you on a spot here if you had to
predict a result and outcome of this
Armageddon what do you think is gonna
happen David I'm gonna stop with you I
think Magnus takes it just because of
the trickiness of the Black Knight but
the clock situation makes it a bit hairy
right now how about you Robert well I
like the clock for federal so I think
that based on what we saw in the
previous game I am going to say that fed
has good chances is he the favorite who
can make that prognostication but I do
think that he has legit chances and I
mean I'm Rook G4 right now can black
actually swap Rooks I fed plays it and
Magnus quickly answers he is keeping the
Rooks on the board he wants more
material on because he's not sure how to
evaluate the end
game yeah yeah if I had to predict I'm
going to predict a big win for big fish
in this one I it just look looks like
with a minute and a half on the clock
and a tricky position Queens on the
board this is going to be a tough one
for Magnus
so wow big moment big moment though I
think he's blundered big fish he needed
to walk out of some Forks the computer
gives it away the Blue Arrow Pawn to C5
and white is defenseless the White Queen
there would have been caught in two
minds he's played it in a different
order same idea with a draw up his
sleeve I think this is good enough
Magnus now he's threatening all sorts if
the white moves there'll be tactics like
Rook takes Pawn in the air the white
Rook here undermined on G4 the white
king is actually a Target the black
pieces combining
now might have it Magnus Carson still
some calculation to be done Robert what
about this what has just happened it's a
travesty for fosa because trading off
Queens here even though Magnus had more
he's like look at this end game we have
even material at least I'll put that in
quotes because black kind of looks like
he's up a pawn or two because all of
Whit's isolated in double Pawn so bnus
is not going to lose this game unless FV
can flag him but that seems unlikely
given how easy it is for Black's move so
Tanya you've you asked the question I'm
gonna pass it back to you any chance for
feda because of the
time I gave you my prediction I mean
with the Queens on the board just three
moves ago I felt like this is going to
be a tough save for Magnus but now with
the trades that we're seeing in fact
Magnus is the one who can push FAL look
at the pawn structure the B Pawn moving
forward the king will be a nice one on
that E6 square a minute on the clock
that's more than enough once the Queens
are traded off am I allowed to change my
predictions wow Magnus gives up his Rook
if Rook takes Rook the black porn would
have just promoted would have walked
down the board beautiful tactics
awareness there from Magnus Carson he's
one a porn he's going to save this game
surely 53 seconds he's a great bullet
player he should have enough this black
seor should win the game let alone a
draw so Robert
he's a miracle now fough he's just given
away his porn Magnus kson why I was sure
he was pre moving but he does have
plenty of time and this is a position
where if you just talk about the chess
there's no chance white ever loses it
but or black lose excuse me but when you
look at the clock fed is going to try to
pressure him but there's no way out you
just force the checks and if the Rooks
come off the board then the last Pawn
drops that's immediately a drw and if
you get the king closer to the Rook The
Rook goes to A2 and you can't defend the
a pawn I a really great practical Choice
by Magnus to give back that pawn and
then to just trade off into everything
35 seconds but David that's more than
enough in this position more than enough
but I like what fed is doing flagging is
encouraged here who cares about morals
just flag the opponent this his last
chance 30 seconds but it is a repetition
Magnus progresses from this Armageddon
wow wow it was so close so close what a
match what a fight by FV he lost early
on in the match
made a comeback took it into Armageddon
and what an Armageddon this was in the
end Magnus Carlson advances into the
Winner's final and will be taking on
Dennis lazic for FV Robert he's got a
lot of reasons to be proud of the fight
he put up today he barely lost this
match yes he goes down to the losers
bracket where he'll await some of the
top guns but you saw that on his face he
just looked clicked on game review and
fedos say like oh no I missed the tactic
so he is you know had chances he should
be proud of it but you could see it
there he's like I I just wasn't looking
in that direction it looked too scary he
did have an opportunity and he may kick
himself later for
that just unreal stuff and what a big
opportunity in fact fosf could have
grabbed the victory at a moment David
what a miss that was we have to rewind
and show in slow motion what he could
have done fed have just had one move
opportunity to win this game to pretty
much knock Magnus down to the losers
bracket but unfortunately no time on the
clock he did miss it and it was
difficult so I think he should forgive
himself for and we can forgive him but
if we get an opportunity I would love to
show that moment as
fed unfortunately got uh got tricked
into that end game Magnus was just too
strong but it was here after Magnus had
actually made a big mistake a grave
error Queen A3 hitting this white Rook
fed reacted but he should not have
trusted the world number one he should
have ignored the threat Bishop takes
Rook this is a beautiful tactic
reminiscent of the Romantic ages of
Chess where you give up one Rook with
Czech you give up a second rook and if
black now takes this Rook you simply
create a big threat Queen takes H1 and
queen to G6 this actually no more checks
no way to defend the G7 Square either
white despite being down a rook delivers
check mate so this opportunity was in
the position he missed it and therefore
gets knocked down to the losers
bracket but have almost had the win
against the world number one game two so
close he gets the job done in game four
it was flagging but it happened and then
in the Armageddon as well but Magnus
Carlson just so hard to beat he keeps
going in the winnner bracket and these
are our score lines the 17-year-old
Dennis lazic did not need a game four to
get the dub in he wraps up his match in
just three games against Jose Martinez
it's going to be D La against Magnus
Carlson tomorrow Robert David I'd love
to get your thoughts looking ahead into
this match between The Clash of
generations well Magnus he said I'll
play Ali Raza for world championship and
no one else but we have other teenagers
on the scene alriza no longer a teenager
himself but Dennis lvic the 17-year-old
he beat Hikaru he beat Anish he beat
Maxim VRA and then he beat the other
Underdog in Jose Martinez so why not
Miracles sometimes they do happen and
why not for Dennis lazic who plays the
best player in chess history the best
player of the last decade at the very
least Magnus Carlson hey the magic can
continue for the
youngster I agree Dennis lazic unbeaten
so far in division one bringing his best
game today was uh very smooth for Dennis
a bit up and down meanwhile for his
opponent tomorrow Magnus so uh that one
anyone's game but of course the losers
uh quarterfinals as well that is going
to be fascinating to watch as those two
players Martinez and FV still have one
life
left absolutely David two more players
will be eliminated of the chille Masters
tomorrow big big fights coming up uh
right now we are going to be joined very
soon with our guest don't go anywhere we
will be back with an interview what a
day it's
[Music]
been
it's crazy oh my God I don't feel it yet
because there's so much spice already in
my mouth TR thermost up please no milk
no fing mil James I'm going to go to the
ambulance what's up everyone chess as
hard as it is but we're about to make it
even harder by playing chili chess for
every type of piece we capture we are
going to eat a chip with some hot sauce
on it starting with the pawns Knights
Bishops and Rooks a queen and then the
loser of the game is going to eat this
drenched chip over here ready to go
yeah we go and here we
go oh man we battled a lot in the it's
like you letting me take it bro we we
get it's you must be hungry bro I'm too
scared to capture take it bro no no no
no cuz then we have to eat the you know
what now you got to eat the freaking
chip all so
big yes
right it feels like I'm inhaling a
barbecue I hate that one that's pretty
good that is the official turn buddy
beautiful that one's weird man it's like
citrusy but like correct kind of tastes
like you know what that's exactly what
it would taste like I'm rolling up my we
got the end game with the
chips this is which one do I want okay
none of you back I like how silent
psychological battle nobody's drank milk
yet right we like
okay all right word looks different when
you high on
spice oh man that boy hitting
different ship's kind of hot to be
chilling like
that it's definitely getting hot in this
room guys you
didn't trying to thermost that
up oh I took I took a pond mister oh you
took a pond you did damn bro you
catching
everything let check oh my God I lost on
time oh my
God okay so the problem is I don't feel
it yet because there's so much spice
already in my mouth so it's probably
going to be like how magnet said it
creeps up on you yeah now it's tur to
creep up I feel it I feel it oh man I'm
going to go to the ambulance
I'm going to call the people right now
on my hand please no milk no milk no
milk we doing this with no milk noing
milk James so two brothers we in a ditch
somewhere y explosions all around no
milk we asked when I'm you need a
Band-Aid no I need no milk sir no
milk I'm going to feel that for a few
days hour I did bro you I did I did but
you your brain don't work right when all
the spikes
no man I can't feel my
fingers same time next
week sure it's a
date
[Music]
a
n
[Music]
a
hello everyone and welcome back to the
Chesser Masters where we are joined by
one of today's winners Magnus Carson and
Magnus first of all congratulations but
what are your first uh thoughts on how
today
went uh yeah the games are pretty
terrible in
general I mean that's not a new take
coming for me but uh yeah that was
um yeah that was not good
but well I prevailed that was more or
less the only good thing but
uh
I yeah just everything was was bad and
my brain was just not working so I'll
have to be a bit better I think coming
up did you feel that your opponent uh
Vladimir fed have played did you feel
that tday was terrible because of how
tough he made it for you or was it just
uh on both
sides no he has a style which is kind of
uncomfortable like he plays very
ambitiously and sometimes makes
non-traditional positional
decisions um which is rather difficult
to face when you're not at your at your
best so it has something to do with his
play as well for sure but if I had a
good day I don't think it would have
been would have been as close as it was
and honestly I mean with with a little
bit of uh Precision he could have pulled
out this this
much uh we were curious in game four it
looked like uh a Time R outs in the end
was it uh just kind of a into freezing
or um what happened
there yeah I just said
like my brain was just fried at that
point and I I couldn't I couldn't think
like I couldn't in my head even remember
like I wasn't even confident that I was
going to hold rook and Bishop against
Rook while if I feel normal I feel that
even with a few seconds that shouldn't
be that shouldn't be an issue so I was
just I was just you know going through
the motions like hoping for the game to
end and then I was choosing the
defensive setup I tried to make a move
but I my movements weren't crisp either
um so yeah that's what
happened and uh it's a new season a new
time control just 10 minutes plus 2
seconds this time um how confident with
you about that Armageddon bid you made
uh what was it around six minutes and a
bit
yeah I saw that that's um approximately
what Maxim B so I thought he generally
has thought about these things he knows
what he's doing so let me do the same so
you've been watching our show or at
least watching the other
games yeah I am a chess fan
so nice to hear nice to get confirmation
and um we do have a few questions from
our chat and one from Krishna
21234 uh Krishna is asking given that
you're playing from a new location do
you think familiarity with the
surroundings or lack thereof uh is
affecting your playing
style um I probably should have gotten a
bigger monitor um that probably would
help apart from that I don't think it
mes too
much konix asks uh Magnus were you
thrown off by fed
speed no I'm I'm used to this style from
from
fedf um this is the way he this is the
way he plays in general like sometimes
he plays a bit better sometimes he plays
a bit
worse um but he he always makes it
difficult for you
by um by playing fighting
non-traditional uh
JZ uh Magnus just before we let you go I
have to ask about tomorrow's winners
final um or sorry the winners final at
least against Dennis lazic how are you
feeling about that one how impressed are
you so far with his
run am I not playing
tomorrow I that was my bad uh the
winners final when it comes around
against
dck I'm not trying to trick you
this no um I mean certainly not easy
um I mean he's been he played really
well last season even in Toronto in the
final he was very
competitive and um I mean this time he's
really defeated a murderer row of uh
players just to get here
so yeah certainly not easy
and I have to up my game a bit cuz today
was uh will probably not be good enough
tomorrow uh I have just got confirmation
you are playing tomorrow so what will
you do to
[Music]
prepare uh I don't know probably not too
much to be honest um some openings
though hey just don't blame me if you
forget to turn up tomorrow it is in fact
happening I
can Magnus congratulations today I'm
going to let you go now get some rest
start preparing those openings and uh
many congratulations
see you tomorrow thank you David see
you and there we had it Magnus Carson
defeating Vladimir fed uh not too happy
with his play but getting the job done
and tomorrow against Dennis Las T yeah
what a match we had today and it's going
to be quite the finner final tomorrow as
the 17-year-old Dennis lazek who is in
such great form he's been playing
phenomenal chess takes on the ultimate
test against the number one Magnus
Carlson I'm really glad that you told
Magnus that he's got to play tomorrow
David he might not have shown up
otherwise I was pretty sure but then he
I don't know he made me doubt myself and
then I backed down and oh poor
Magnus he's got bad influences around
him trust me David you were like fedos
over there you trusted Magnus a little
bit too much you know you should have
been firm with him and let him know that
you were correct in in this
position next time let's hope you shuts
up
he will show up and we're going to have
a great winner final but Robert it was
also so interesting to see that Magnus
was critical about his match despite
winning it yeah he is an honest
objective assessor of his own play he
really is happy when he feels like he
truly played a brilliant game and he's
unhappy when he feels like there were
improvements that he should have spotted
but it's funny because his not best
effort is still good enough he makes it
through to the winnner finals unlike
some of our other players who had a say
goodbye to the tournament as their run
ended today yeah and two more we'll say
goodbye tomorrow but let's take a look
at where we stand at the cherel Masters
and these are the standings Maxim bash
lra Wesley so with losses today are out
of the tournament and they get the
paycheck uh coming their way the
meanwhile the others continue and the
Fight Continues and the winner will get
a spot into the season and final lots
more chess coming up David what was the
highlight for you in today's matches
well I've got to say the uh incredible
Checkmate we saw earlier today it feels
like a livetime ago now but Yan Nomi
delivering checkmate with a queen
sacrifice fuja Landing some nice
sacrifices of his own and then that
Armageddon that one with Magnus Carson
and FV we didn't know who was going to
win until right near the end till the
last few seconds it was fast it was fun
and uh ultimately Magnus prevailed
yeah
and I'm going to give the floor to you
one more time before we sign off for the
day what was the what impressed you
today so much impressed me I mean we saw
blunders we saw brilliancies and we just
saw people fighting their hearts out two
players had to leave the tournament but
even though he didn't win his match I
have to give a shout to Vladimir fos he
proves each and every match that he is a
worthy Contender yesterday he stormed
back from a deficit to take down Ali rea
fuia today he gave Magnus Carlson
everything he could handle and was oh so
close to Knocking the number one player
in the world down to the losers bracket
so I would say that lavic continues to
shine he beat that murderous row as
Magnus called it Magnus himself he's
always impressive but then I would say
third honors go to Vladimir feda because
yeah he was Stellar even in defeat and
he will be back tomorrow in the losers
bracket fighting on his last life but
what a performance by him today against
the world number one and trustable
Masters continues into a big big day
tomorrow in the elimination bracket and
in the winners final today was a day of
heartbreaks and celebration lots of
twists and turns what big moments we've
had it's been a dramatic day chat we
will see you
[Music]
tomorrow
he
[Music]
oh
w